all right reject nation you know what to
do tell us if we're live tell us
sound off in the c-h-a-t chat we're
grateful to see you all
here to talk doctor strange too in the
multiverse of madness spoilers
second question can you hear us okay
because we're gonna hop into this
immediately we're going to hop into this
fastly are we in stereo are we in
beautiful stereo we need to know the
sounds
we need to know if the sounds are good a
live stream yeah
what
the lie being capitalized makes it a
little extra this is live you're able to
do this in uh youtube yes
what is this live stream all right we
sound good
all right so since we're here guys if
you can leave a like that would be
amazing
thank you so much for being here we're
just getting warmed up right now hells
yeah john and i are doing
better than coy's ever been in his
entire life
no one yeah and uh we're gonna just have
a fun time talking about this and you
guys will help drive the narrative of
this spoiler talk today since so much
happened in this movie
all right so really quick since coy was
not with us on the channel talk about
doctor strange post seeing a koi
koi my my son
hates so rapidly i've become older than
you
i'm a boy
um they're saying koi's mic sound is off
i thought we handled this oh no
good thing we caught it before i ranted
this is why we asked you guys beforehand
we appreciate we actually ran a test
first time in a year i need to be yeah
this is uh that's a real thing can't
hear co coy's mike's too quiet that's
the first time anyone's ever said i was
too quiet
all right all right snow yeah
boys mikey's mute no way well that was
seconds ago we got a little ketchup
delayed boy
i went from muted to [ __ ]
very quickly
all right i'm gonna assume we're fine
like it's good now perfect all right
thank you jesus all right so
koi my my child
who can you
tell the audience
what did you think about doctor strange
in the multiverse madness i thought that
if you're a sam raimi fan you're gonna
have the best time you may have ever had
in the cinema because it was sam raimi
um getting the opportunity to actually
have a budget worthy of his creativity i
thought if you were a die hard marvel
fan you might have mixed experiences and
i think if you're a die-hard mcu fan
this might not be for you uh it is a
very
versatile film in many ways but it's
also a very unapproachable film in other
ways i am personally not much of a
horror fan i'm not generally one that
leans camp so i enjoyed a lot of this
but i think i enjoyed other people's
experiences more than mine i think i
enjoyed the fact that a lot of people
are going to get the sam raimi movie of
their dreams but as someone who will
take the andrew garfield spider-man's
over the toby maguire spider-man's i can
objectively see that the sam raimi
universe is not exactly my tempo as much
as i love sam the individual as much as
i love the world's same as built as much
as i give sam raimi credit for the mcu
existing byway of spider-man i think
it's blade x-men and spider-man that
this exists for today and i give sam
raimi a huge amount of that credit it
doesn't mean that it's necessarily for
me so this movie while enjoyable i saw
it twice already and i had a good time
both times is not one that's gonna be in
my top half of the mcu it's somewhere in
that bottom third for me because i do
feel like it unfortunately undermined a
lot of the things that i enjoy about
wanda uh i do personally feel that the
way it concludes didn't further the mcu
in ways that i thought would be um
lasting okay and i think i and i do
think that there is an element of um of
linear in the chaos that surprised me
because it leaned very heavily creative
in many ways while also kind of having
one trajectory that it lived through in
others so uh you know i i i enjoyed it
uh it is still even though it's in the
lower third of marvel for me that's
still a bb plus movie because the mcu is
so consistent and it's still amongst my
favorite sam raimi films because this is
that beautiful blend of chaos and marvel
but uh as far as you know the the phase
four experience it's not up there with
uh you know shang chi or no way home for
me wow
wow so uh it's like in the in the middle
tier you said for you from okay all
right i'm being honest people think i
like everything i'm trying to be
objective and as much as i love if you
don't like something you're wrong that's
true i just want you to know that that's
true and here's everything and when you
don't like it and then i just get out
you're an addict
get out
is what i said you know what you know
what my favorite part is is that we are
discussing multiverse of matt we're
discussing dr strange in the
here we are the multiverse of moms i
believe that's the only way sam raymond
would have signed him it's the ninth
american pie film the multiverse of
mom's
this movie should have been called the
scarlet witch it did feel more like a
this felt more like a the dark hole of
madness than the multiverse i agree with
that in being a sequel to both one
division and doctor strange i do feel
like in some ways it it almost doesn't
feel like a full sequel to either
yeah i felt like the multi-verse i
thought it was madness though it was
certainly madness i thought it was man i
don't agree with that assessment if you
have an issue with like the lack of
multiverse it does have that x-men
origins issue with the trailers and show
you like wow look at all that [ __ ]
they're going to explore but oh it's a
montage
in age of ultron me so hard like it gave
me the ultron to you yeah where it was
like here's the cool scenes in the
trailer and then you're gonna wait for
them like i don't know how many tweets i
saw that were like if they showed that
in the trailer imagine what they haven't
shown yeah yeah yeah a couple moments
and and like that's not sam raimi's
fault that's not the movie's fault but
if i had gone into this not having seen
a certain shield or no oh this is the
spoiler talk not having seen the captain
carter shield or not having seen
professor x with the beautiful yellow
hoverboard of justice uh then perhaps i
would have had a better time if i wasn't
going into this expecting my brain to
experience multiverses i didn't get to
experience which isn't the movie's fault
imagine if we got to see this and we
hadn't heard the rumors or actually seen
some things it might have even been a
whole letter great higher to be honest
dang
fair enough my expectations were really
high because of them like the ads were
for in universe this movie and it just
wasn't uh it wasn't as expansive as the
ads implied
well i thought it was a super duper and
both times i've seen it i liked it i
liked it a little more the second time i
saw it yeah did you like it less i liked
it more yeah i liked it a lot more first
because it was a b minus one up to a b
first time i watched it i was like whoa
this is ridiculously fast
the second time i'm like oh it's not as
fast as i thought remember when i called
you after the first 20 minutes yeah and
i was like because the first 20 minutes
are fast because the first 20 minutes
are insane you got to keep up with the a
lot of information and it and it also
introduces you in the film drops and
you're like here's a brand new character
and a variant version of a character
we've met so you're not seeing anyone
you know technically and you're thrown
into this multiverse of madness where
you're just getting exposition
exposition exposition and it's also like
the least sam raimi seen in the film the
opening for whatever reason is like all
cgi and green screen and the rest of the
movie leans way better into the rainy of
it all so i was really worried with the
first 20 minutes and then it then it got
me back see i was happy that we didn't
really cover like rumors or anything
like that yeah because
i wasn't i didn't actually walk out the
the thing i didn't walk away out of was
going i thought there'd be a lot more
cameos i really didn't actually think
that and i thought it was just fine in
that that was that was never one of my
issues with the movie but i know that's
something that's let a lot of people
down was that sentiment of expectations
i didn't want more necessarily i just
didn't want to know the ones we had but
it didn't like let me down i i didn't
there was nothing in my my expectations
i kind of i just wanted a super
entertaining film and a gate for me it
really gave me that i was i'm thoroughly
even when it starts to sometimes movies
like start off entertaining and then dip
and it just stays that way or some
movies are start off low and then they
eventually get entertaining this had
this unique ability where sometimes it
was like okay this this scene is kind of
slowing down a little bit it's like kind
of dipping but then it would get really
entertaining again yeah okay it's kind
of oh it was really entertaining again
and for the most part i was just
extremely entertained from beginning to
end especially watching this on imax and
getting like a good seat because we saw
it at the uh we saw it at the premiere
you know
they're like you're youtubers you're
going to be all the way in the back in
the very back
going gonna watch the screen at this
weird angle off to the side and uh i'm
not sure i can appreciate the frame of
this movie everything is thicker on the
right yeah everyone on the right hand
side of the screen is your favorite
character because that's all you're
seeing i'm not complaining though i i i
want to let uh you know everyone at
disney know that when you when you bring
us i appreciate it it's just fun to be
there yeah regardless but it looks like
in the chat uh i move as i've been
skimming the comments as you guys i'm
letting them in yeah leave your thoughts
in the comments that
a lot of people seem to be more in the
middle about this movie yeah i put up a
poll and most people said the movie
pretty decent
yeah pretty decent pretty decent than
the second mostly you show that poll on
screen i feel like a b is that i feel
like we're on the same page people
yelling at me inevitably
of course because you admitted you
didn't really like a movie i said it was
a b
it's not as good as other things that's
there are other things i enjoyed more
the cinema that's that's lower than the
cinema score i'm i'm my own man i'm my
own man greg i think you got to conform
to other people's opinions all the time
i mean that's what they want do you
think we go do videos that's what br
breaks my heart when the embargo hasn't
lifted i'm like what's everyone else
saying i must actually have sex what are
the people saying how am i going to
contrive my opinion how do i have an
opinion without others opinions yeah
yeah let me talk to everyone here and
try to get engaged whatever else is
really what rotten tomatoes is going to
land what are you putting on twitter
please tell me
um
actually i like the turtles more koi
like a real honest thought i'll give you
guys i'm so honest that i'll i'll admit
when i'm a bit insecure about things um
is that what did i text you the other
day then i love being honest that's my
favorite thing is to be honest and i
stand by it and so a lot of times i will
not
want to look up others opinions or
whatever just so i like i know how i
feel or how i think i don't i don't
really socialize with people when i'm
screening is done and it's true
i look forward and i don't remind you
this is a common problem for me because
i'm like hey i want to introduce greg to
blankety like greg's gone greg's been
gone for half an hour actually though to
be fair i've heard a lot of like just
the career movie critics say like
especially when you're doing screenings
and you're doing multiple a day like
they're like no no i jet because i don't
want to sit there and dissect the movie
like we all got to go write our own
things yeah yeah yeah so i love being
honest um
but then
when i when i put my i'll i'll make the
video i upload it and then i go oh i
start to get a little panicky though if
it's not going to line up with the
majority of people's opinions so that's
it that's what always happens to me that
i'm like oh [ __ ] i already said it you
know that's the best
i will take the slight bit of panic over
the
the slight bit of worry that it's gonna
just i don't know i don't even know what
the worry is based in just people like
yelling at me and showing up in my dms
about not agreeing with them
i don't i don't know what it's based in
life yeah i think i think it's it's
wanting to be yeah i think it's wanting
to be like like-minded i think that's
like human nature is like tribalism uh
my mom is in the chat it's mother's day
happy mother's day happy coy's mother's
day that's what the day that's what it
is boy don't blame the movie for your
high expectations i blame my
expectations on quality of the marvel
you're only gonna read coy's hate
comments that's it actually it's nice
having the chat here actually it's nice
having some koi hate yeah yeah you got
to balance it out
i'm sorry i expect we're usually so
positive about you yeah uh do we have we
have a few super chats let's get to them
yeah we have to have a hard out of here
on this live stream because it's
mother's day uh i'm going to try to end
this no later than because we attend a
beer for like five hours so i'm going to
try to end this at exactly like 2 33ish
exactly exactly
an entire tv show could play uh but yeah
let's read some of these really uh let's
read some of these let's enjoy it while
we're here yes let's marinate moms did
you guys get your mom something from
mother's day do you know your mom did
your mother abandon you um how's that
working out for you did you find her in
another multiverse after you lost her in
this one i'm gonna call my mom after
this there we go i'm not a monster i'm a
mother
i i think they should one day do like a
proper wanda movie accurate house of m
movie i think they need to
dick some things with water i think so i
like that
i loved wanda but they went from the the
mcu gave us like one through six of her
arc and then this gave us nine and ten
of her arc and i didn't get to see seven
and eight and they did such a good job
laying out her beautiful arc
painstakingly and
like particularly and with much
precision and then they were like
turn i'm just so used to movies uh shows
doing that i just did i'm used to tv
shows doing like time jump character
different but
did such a good job making it nuanced
true
all right let's talk about the people
let's talk about what the people are
saying really quick talk about what the
people say
all right q1 thank you so much for the
moment of silence to kick us off thanks
q1 thank you
nasaki unsaki and saki i wish
we would have saw superior iron man tom
cruise
i think i do think tom cruise or a
superior iron man was in this movie
originally when they were first
releasing those illuminati shots but
they had to let go i wonder who's in
there which i i know they do that to
specifically get people speculating like
to my understanding
what these studios want you to speculate
off of is what they're
teasing for you so yes they want rumors
they want that they don't want leaks but
they want like rumors the conversation
is the ad they want people to theorize
based off what they are giving to us and
when they first uh we're showing like
illuminati stuff and i've seen people
even reuse like images of it
is there's seven seats
there's seven chairs interesting and you
know this movie was like uh fairly close
to its release date they re-shot it and
they re-edited the movie and it does
make me wonder like who was
that seventh seat or if they trolled
to have us talk about it right now like
to have a conversation like usually they
cgi something out i love the idea
the whole kind of whole sequence an end
game that doesn't exist right what are
you gonna say john maybe they just were
very sentimental and they're like look
mordo we'll give you a new chair because
you're the new sorcerer supreme but
we're going to keep steve's old chair
yeah
we're bummed that we had to have a black
bolt do that yeah yeah
it's actually
well i think they're going to be
spreading out some of these surprise
cameos throughout the course of this
whole secret wars setup that they're
doing they're obviously getting a secret
wars yeah i've been thinking about a lot
about how phase 4 feels so like you know
disparate and i do think that's an
intentional thing it's going to come
together yeah i think it's going to come
together with something huge
all right matt beerus it's been a while
since we've seen you matt beer thanks
for being here bud what up guys really
had a blast with it i'm glad to hear
that that's where you're supposed to
feel cool daddy's happy he's also nice
and has good taste in beer jerk i'm glad
people are happy boy just doesn't have
fun yeah that's the secret he walks away
from him it's my secret capital
ass woke agenda that's right this movie
like the turtles woke agenda for me and
goes my favorite part is guys making out
with each other yeah
touching each other's ass is just
each other on screen and i'm like wow
koi that's all you care about that's all
i'm focusing on like here going there's
not enough punch punch in there you're
shiny objects
philosophy shiny objects butt touching
this was a total art film half of it was
at magic hour koi
this wasn't enough hand holding in the
team
all joking put to decide permanently for
the rest of the stream um that's gonna
happen
what i think is so cool about this movie
is that i really felt like it does do
like a supernatural horror
and sci-fi
mashup together and absolutely to me
that's just so fun and there's some of
the most inventive sequences like that
fight scene at the end uh not the fights
at the very end i mean that was cool but
the the musical number one the composer
supreme so beautiful so beautifully
realized every time i watch it i'm like
this is one of the coolest things i
loved that sequence but it made me
realize how much that sequins could have
been everything she can literally invent
universes and she used her powers to go
pew pew and shoot laser beam like like
scarlet witch can literally talking
about scarlet witch can reinvent real
talking about the doctor strange yeah
i'm saying that could have been
everything wanda did like wanda has the
ability to like literally create from
nothing and instead they made her like
pew pew with little red laser blasts all
right it's it's and sam raimi's a genius
of creativity and that scene showed it
and then that's all we got
i mean she made that one guy run that's
cool
she got in that one guy's head that was
a cool moment that's what i'm saying is
like those moments show us what could
have been oh my god imagine if she
murked the illuminati that way if she
just got it if you isolated all of them
and made her like you know mind
manipulate them and make them fight each
other yeah keep black boys that would be
cool keep black bolt the same because
that's that was
every time i've seen it the audience has
been like and i've walked into that
scene for i've seen that scene four
times and like it is such a crowd
that like i'm surprised at the amount
they were able to do with that anyway uh
q crew what was your guys favorite part
mine was wong climbing up the cliff
thank you
very much
every single one
climbing up the cliff man likes cliffs
when it became like a meditative
experience of wong's survival journey
going through i will write everything
i want to wang i will watch a wong solo
movie all day any day i don't care what
he's doing i think wong's a little
underrated yeah
he is underrated but i was very very
pleased at how much love he got both
screenings yes the screenings people are
like wong well wong is uh
benedict wong
is such is so different
like his personality is so different
from wong the character oh he's so funny
and he's such like a lively dude he's
like so chill yeah like sarcastic that's
what i mean by like his energy is so
like uh oh and it made me appreciate his
performances because when i saw wong in
the first doctor strange i kind of just
assumed like
i mean i went like oh he must be like a
foreign actor that they brought over
here and he's british
yeah i've never minded you're like not
that guy at all and it made me
appreciate him that much more when i
realized how much i believed he was like
some international actor they hired they
hired me in this movie um yeah i think i
think he's great in this film and i this
movie did have me concerned that he
would die yeah i actually bought yeah
for a moment and i love benedict moon's
performance also like you're saying that
the guy himself like he's such a an
interesting performer and it makes wong
it elevates wong from the comics to be
honest when wong is like tied up see
what i thought was cool about the reveal
because they're going through like
wanda's perspective as she's dream
walking but but i think raymie knows how
to play with the camera so well it's
like i'm not going to show you this side
of the screen though yet yeah wait a
while and then when it's revealed that
you're like okay in wanda's world it's
it's like she's experiencing this joyful
thing from dreamwalking then when it
pans around it's just like a nightmare
at comma dodge and long side up and i
that's when i started wondering if wong
might actually die and that was a blast
like those things really worked for me
especially visually there's so many
frames in this that feel like a comic
book true it's stunning i agree i agree
all right all righty you know i the
other thing i'll just say really quick
is that i i love that wong and strange
while there's so much happening their
relationship and the growth of that
really does feel plugged in and the
whole battle thing that was great uh
brezzy osa thank you so much for jumping
in here uh do y'all think this means
john krasinski is gonna be our reed
richard john did you go first on this
it better mean that because i think
people would be really upset if this
would like if they do a ralph boner on
this and they give you this fan casting
and then completely recast him or just
bring joe and griffith back
i think people will be upset so uh i
think this is our actual read richard
then i think he'll get a proper intro
but i do think that like this intro is a
little funky
yeah introducing the fox characters and
and also reintroducing an iconic fox
character as a five-minute sequence
which was great
is an odd choice and i do think john
krasinski needs to come back
for it to be the reed richards that we
all have wanted because i i do feel like
it's really directly bonering if if they
do just like let that be his only
secrets i could see them not like uh we
just lost a visual i'm not bad that was
me um we lost visual we lost visual we
lost visual
i do think we could not because um you
know he could be a variant and we've
seen how people look different and like
you know the variety of options but now
that they also need a director i'd love
to see grazinski direct fantastic four
as well as be reid richards maybe emily
blunt is gonna be number three of the
controlling wives in hollywood and not
let him
is this is this a thing it was two
there's always people are attacking the
wives in hollywood oh then we had the
amber situation we have the jason they
were tuition amber and johnny were
married
let's make the live stream about this i
don't pay attention um
and no i think emily will be 100
supportive i know she didn't really want
to do it but i wonder if they can work
together
directed it and then she'd be like a
quiet place
he's going to drag her into that movie
yeah you're doing sue storm for me
but you said [ __ ] though that's what
the illuminati well i think i think
krazynski it would be disappointing i
think there are people who wanted more
from it because a for me i even crave
more from reed richards not because oh
man i wanted to see more i'm like no as
in terms of like context of the
character
everyone on the illuminati and we put
this up in our video that we put up
earlier today that everyone in the
illuminati felt a little bit like one
note and stoic they all kind of felt
like the same kind of you know council
authority like there was there was
nothing that really
shine unique about either of anyone's
personality there and with reed richards
like it was just like serious john
kozinski as john puts it you know you
don't really feel like it's reed
richards yeah and there wasn't time to
settle in with because i could never
just see reed richards i was so aware
every moment because that like that's
john krasinski he looks like how people
photoshopped him all the time
yeah and and then when he first like you
know um stretches down people cheer
because they're like we're about to see
him do mr fantastic [ __ ] and then he
dies yeah
while i loved that moment i thought they
were going to die i genuinely love that
moment i do [ __ ] when i do step back i
go this would have been more rewarding
if there was like a real fight to let
that fan fulfillment happen especially
if he doesn't come back but that's where
i stand maybe he'll come back let's move
on lily breezy qsa lily aguilera thank
you so much hello guys i met you guys at
universal city lily we remember you yes
i gotta remember you for a very very
specific reason i'll get it too in a
second thank you for being nice terrible
by the way terrible reason we faked the
entire niceness do you think we were
like get away from me
they called me do you think wanda went
too far in this movie love you too there
was someone who recognized us it was
like hey is it is koi here yes like
jesus
yes get away from me mikey i remember
you mikey no lily how many musketeers
are there the reason we remember you is
because like the reason why they'll
always stand out to me is gonna sound um
a little
strange
is
normally like we've been recognized by
ladies before
what's the proper term to not sound like
a pervert women
no
because girls weird
you are calling me woke agenda and
you're trying to figure out how to say
not male 1
for male 1
anyone femme presenting no it's like
that's only been at like when we're at
comic-con or at some event and this was
the first time we've ever just been out
in public
and a a woman has come up to us
in all these years i'd be like i watch
you guys and i'm like really like
are you algorithmic are you one of the
fourteen percent yeah i don't know it's
so it was so much like you are names
because as any time a woman is
recognized as too they're usually like
you're the you're like the real rejects
guys
you're the trailer guys right and so
this is the first thing like i love you
greg and john and i'm like wow this is
so weird it's never happened before all
these years
it took getting close to a million
subscribers for that to happen that's
when that's the threshold uh
but nah thank you lily that was really
you're you're incredibly sweet so it was
really lovely meeting you that's uh
thank you so you hold i'll never forget
the first person that recognized us
either years ago a man named carlos
carlos now the question oh yeah the
question do i think wanna went too far
in this movie god no no
she didn't go far enough she didn't go
far enough man i mean we i know we know
house of m wanda who's literally like
[ __ ] the world
everyone everyone and that wanda's
really like mad that she is the madness
one she she is the
the one that would be a a real true
problematic portrayal i would have
honestly i want the full commitment to
wanda just desperate to get her kids and
then just loses her [ __ ] like and takes
it out on the world like i want that
wanda i do as much as there might be
people complaining on twitter about that
portrayal i personally think that would
be awesome for as far as what we got
here uh i thought it was great it was so
cool to see the mcu at least take the
step forward of going
she's gonna be the villain in this movie
she's really gonna be the villain i was
under the impression before going this
my expectation was
there's going to be another villain and
one and straight are going to team up
that's what i thought i'm like no she
was the villain throughout and then when
she started killing people like
comartage that's when i was going yes
kill kill away murder them and so when
she's murdering the illuminati
that just elevates how powerful she is
she doesn't even get defeated she has to
defeat herself
in order for this fight to end like
literally it's a it's a emotional
character arc for her so i think wanda
could have even gone further for what we
got though i thought it was great i did
find it weird how she spent more time
fighting ultron bots in the illuminati
but other than that it was great try and
strong i uh i do trump
i found that i liked it but i don't feel
like it was it like i said my one
through six and then eight nine ten like
i was sorry nine and ten i was missing
seven and eight and i do feel like that
is the character from the comic books
and i do feel like but she's too far but
like that's what i mean it's like she
went too far without the context like
they didn't actually give us the reason
like that that pivot on the visual
exchange of apple orchard to red dark
hold
what uh what a dark hole corrupts you
koi they said it in the film that means
it's enough with one line of dialogue
it's just i don't know like she has so
much more nuance in the comments
and yeah because of my expectations for
morbius was i was gonna watch a 90s
vampire movie my expectations spice up
this livestream
my expectations for the mcu and sam
raimi is that you get a nuanced take on
a character that's got 60 years of
history and like i think liz olsen
brought that gravitas but i think the
dialogue didn't allow it and that that
hurt it for me no that's fair i respect
your opinion thank you but i will fight
you on the stream i understand just
because it's more exciting here's some
content
flip it out quick uh johnny why don't
you take the next question since we
hogged that one up a bit
lcd0685 just because someone stumbles
and loses their way it doesn't mean
they're lost forever please stop killing
professor x for once i only died three
times this is the third time out of how
many x-mens like eight
it's like a one per three i will
personally stop killing professor x
i was controlling your thoughts on
professor x john uh you know he's there
uh it's nice
it's nice to see patrick stewart again
and i liked his moment and in fact
i really appreciated how
it highlighted the most like the whole
illuminati scene is basically a delay
diversion tactic thing and so what i
thought was most clever is that once
wanda's done dealing with him she's like
oh [ __ ] they got away and i'm like yeah
he created a diversion and i totally
didn't even realize it so i like that i
mean yeah like uh patrick stewart brings
his own gravitas just wherever he goes
and it's always great to see him don you
know professor x and it's the same thing
i think we're gonna probably say a lot
today which is i would have loved to
have seen a little more and i feel like
what applies to the whole illuminati but
especially professor x's
the one shortcoming is i wish they had
convinced me like he's got a shot he
could actually you know sort this out
they got this covered oh [ __ ] no they
don't like as much as it does
speak to wanda's insane level of power
that she can vanquish especially
professor x and all the rest of them i
would have liked to have at least had
that moment of like oh maybe they could
actually make a difference in this fight
oh no they they're not gonna
uh but yeah like it was fun to see him
and i just would have loved to see more
yeah i guess it would especially after
coming i think what it factors into is
like coming off of no way home where you
bring back these legacy performers and
then you you really utilize them like
they become they're actual characters
and they're nuanced
and for here i think it was that weird
feeling this is something i do blame on
the trailers it was that weird feeling
of ut's patrick stewart in here
and
i'm like you didn't need to do that
because he really was just a cameo and
it was a really cool moment in the movie
clearly set up as a surprise because he
wasn't even there at the top so like to
to have us waiting for him felt really
like it undersold it but i think that
scene when he dies is a suspenseful ass
scene like oh that seems cool but he
shows up and he's like
and he hops into the mind of her like
that is this that is a really like
creepy sequel the sequences work it's a
it's a movie with a series of incredible
sequences yes and also i gotta give
credit to the crowd on opening night and
not the premiere
uh because when he said that line
someone stumbles in this way like the
premier crowd was way more engaged from
beginning to end it was cheering
non-stop but they did not react to that
line at all like no one did
but then at the opening night which was
way less engaged of a crowd yet when
that line came up like the whole theater
was like clapping and like and uh even i
had to go wait where's that line from
he talks to james mcavoy and he says
that yeah
right i will yes
but before we move on apologies i do
think it's worth noting that my
negatives are coming from a place of i
think the mcu is the greatest of the the
universes that have been built so this
is better than morbius or venom and
those those films so like when i'm the
fighter negative no no no i'm justifying
my
expectations morphe is sweet orbeez
but but i think it's fair to look at
these things as comic book films and
this is superior to that world
is it superior strange it is
at times don't keep justifying your your
negativity i'm having opinions today
lapping poor aquara in the main chat
really quick says in the cinema there
were a lot of kids parents may have
regretted taking them and uh greg
definitely i think overheard some of
that i heard some kids
really vocalizing how scared they were i
was like these poor children it's only
going to get worse justin martin
freaking one was like crawling out of
that mirror like a ring girl
i'm so sorry yeah people got mad at me
for saying it was scary when i in my
non-spoiler review and i was like it is
scary like those kids were like what
is
super sexy reject justin justin martin
thanks buddy justin in the chat hey guys
this movie was so refreshing and it's
more defining character choices despite
what koi says about everything wrong
with this film wanda's entire arc the
illuminati subversion etc what is your
favorite character choice in this film
i have a favorite character moment that
now i'm quoting because no one points it
out i'm questioning if it's actually
what is the internet thing craig you
know i wonder if it's intelligence i
don't hear anyone pointed out and to me
for some reason it hits as such a cool
reveal
um
which is the
how do i put it okay
you know how america has this constant
fear that like strange is gonna like
betray her and kill her you know yeah
the whole movie
and when he come when strange meets
sinister strange and sinister strange
like i want confirmation as to who that
you're who you are and then he brings up
the memory of their sister who died
and to me that rings so
true to why he will not kill america why
he chooses to protect her because that's
the first thing that comes to mind
our strange holds on to so much guilt
and then in that scene what's revealing
to me about that character choice to
reveal that like i know it's in the
comics and such but to reveal that was
such a good indicator of like my sister
died in a frozen lake
and to me that would instantly told me
this is why he's the strange that will
not kill america chavez i will not
sacrifice her because it was such an
important character reveal and for some
reason
when i watched the movie the second time
so much of his performance feels based
off of that one reveal that seems to be
like kind of in passing for a lot of
folks just as like a line to explain how
he gets into this conversation with him
but to me i feel like that gives a good
indicator of his core memories of what
forms strange into the person that he is
as someone who is look a lot colder on
the surface but really this is why he
became a doctor that's why i became a
surgeon to save lives this is why he is
still a hero despite his cold exterior
he's actually someone who wants to help
and save people because of that core
memory right there and he holds on to
that so much i like that yeah and i i
hadn't thought of it to that level i i
definitely appreciated that moment given
too much credit you know you know what
greg
i liked that moment but i i hadn't given
it that many layers so i yeah i think
that's really special my defining uh
moment is when he basically
is both arrogant enough to think he can
uh wield the
dead and also willing to sacrifice
whatever he knows is going to be the
cost because that's dr strange to me is
he's always willing to shoulder the cost
he's always willing to to sacrifice
himself but also there's a certain
amount of arrogance in being like yeah
i'm gonna make this dead cape and like
that entire sequence like the whole uh
sequence with the cloak of the damned
was incredible but it also came from a
place of benedict cumberbatch really
wielding the character away that felt
authentic to my years of loving him yeah
for sure john come on character moment
i'll keep thinking
it past what you guys said because you
guys pretty much i thought you were
gonna say the scene when you cried
uh
it's a character choice i mean yeah it
definitely did touch me at the end when
he when he'd choose it when he chooses
to hand off the knife basically when he
uh just says you know basically yes
america no i'm not going to take your
power you're the one who has to do that
you're the one who is capable and and
who has you know what we need i am not
the one who can make the only one choice
you know to to solve this problem you
know you need to step into your power
that you can absolutely wield that you
absolutely have the ability to command
and you can you know hold the knife i
thought you're going to talk about when
like wanda confronts herself and that's
a beautiful moment oh yeah says that's
the thing is is it you know yeah that's
another that's another one of my
favorite moment i like uh that's always
a very effective moment on me is when
you know someone's transported and you
can see
the outside version of them where it's
like you know this whole pursuit of
yours if your kids ever actually knew
what you were trying to do like body
swap their mom they'd be freaking
terrified of you and so yeah the the
whole reclamation between the two of
them and that back and forth and that
acknowledgement of the pain and the fact
that wanda ultimately has to accept that
i'm just gonna have to live i don't
believe she's dead so i'm you know kind
of accepting like i'm just gonna have to
carry this pain because i know out there
there are versions of them that are uh
you know being loved yeah which is
really hard to do and and you know in a
multi-verse is easier to do than uh only
verifiable universe like we have here
anyway it's ante
thank you for chiming in i feel like
marvel should just ignore critics who
say marvel is formulaic every time they
try to mix it up there's backlash but
audience rotten tomato score is still
very high well thanks for the uh super
chat there at zante um
i mean i think mixing up is what keeps
it fresh i mean i think that the fact is
that if it followed the same structure
that every
marvel movie like there was a time where
it did feel like there's a very specific
marvel formulaic structure
but mix honestly spider-man no way home
is not marvel formula and that movie is
mixed it up insanely and did an amazing
job spectacular job in my opinion i
think phase four has done such a good
job being so different there's so much
going on i think winter soldiers often
hailed as one of the top three best mcu
films and i don't consider that
formulaic yeah winter soldier's my
number two afternoon at home two of them
that broke the formula for me they both
have really interesting villains and
choices i think shang chi is more
formulaic out of the phase four films i
think shang chi black widow that's like
mcu formulaic
but i i that's why i even give eternals
credit for at least mixing it up you
know even though i didn't really like
the movie i at least i'm like all right
at least you tried something they did a
good job in this phase for a lot of the
villain work too making them really be
not the same
powers but evil yeah yeah yeah yeah well
i think the shows are still the best
thing to come out of other than
spider-man noah home which was so you
know i like this movie a lot though i i
think this movie is like su
it is one of those things that
i don't often think about it when i'm
not talking about it does that make
sense there's like no way home was a
film just like i just kept thinking
about like i was obsessed with it
this one is i'm so
entertained by it when i'm watching it
i'm loving the visuals and the horror
aesthetic but when it's not done but
when it's done
i don't i don't really think about it
much yeah yeah like going into your life
like that yeah i enjoyed that but when
i'm there i'm loving it that's one of
the
weird experiences about it so i guess it
does not really have this like super
long lasting impact for me but it's been
on my mind
john can't stop thinking about it it's
been on my mind he was trying to make
love to me the other day but i could see
his mind was elsewhere i'm like why
won't you look at me alone
life without borders thank you so much
for chiming in no matter what the
universe captain marvel's too cocky and
overconfident as always you know what i
like you should smile more man
i'll see see of all the illuminati i
thought that she had the most
personality her and and and just the
natural haley atwell personality that
that shines through peggy carter i
thought the two of the two captains had
the most personality and i also really
enjoyed that if you look at that scene
on the actual council captain marvel
will be getting all the like little
push-ins like every time she makes a
quip there's like a little camera
portion i'm like cool well she's she's
like aggressive yeah
and even when she's fighting like
all offense that that that
teeth grind made everyone go is that tom
cruise
no that's how she feels about that
i know right
um but yeah like her her actual fighting
presents more
you know i think personality than what
honestly what bree larson brings um it
just in a little bit of role like even
because when bruce larsen's being
captain marvel it's just kind of just
like he's like kind of a neutral like
flying stoic you know
i enjoyed her a lot as captain marvel
and i also think that you know that was
one of the characters that showed the
expanse of options in the universe
because the personification was true and
whereas like when we haven't really been
invested in black bolt we haven't really
been invested we haven't met reid now we
kind of have i've been demanding i've
been demanding black bull come back
long time yeah like that turning fork i
like gotta have it i lie i thought
anthony mount for for and not having
seen the inhumans show i thought he had
a lot of presence for his brief time i i
was i enjoyed him in this i mean his
character's at a disadvantage for like
having lots of personality because
obviously but yeah i thought he in his
expressions had a lot of
presence yeah infinity war also not for
me like endgame not formulaic and two of
the best mcu if i'm just putting that
out 30 now
um karina moravid thanks karina i
thought it was amazing in one of my top
mcu movies everyone did amazing but
every but elizabeth olsen exceeded
expectation
it was so amazing amazing probably you
know when i saw this amazing thing
i did not actually know this was going
to be a theme probably the best
performance in mcu history in my opinion
i personally think um elizabeth olsen is
my
from what she did in wanda vision to do
something here that is so different from
wanda vision and yet still be the
highlight performer for like everyone
would most people agree that like i
don't really
i feel like the wanda vision of the way
it ended and then the post-credits scene
like do i think it's a little bit of a
cop out for it to be like it's the dark
hole taking over her a little bit i do
like like i said i was okay with it a
second ago i would no i i would prefer
wanda being just crazy one in her kids
like i know that would be like an issue
for a lot of people but i for some
reason i think this is cooler um
i i think like it's a tad bit but what
elizabeth olsen does with that role i
think she's so menacing she becomes so
she just gets scarier as the movie goes
when she is
after she kills the illuminati and she
is just full-on terminator yeah slash
velociraptor just charging at them with
like she is covered in like ultron blood
and her feet for some reason she did not
grab sandals on the way out of the house
i'm going barefoot walking on rubble and
glassing and i'm just trying like she is
just this
in like this force of nature and she's
so scary and i like i love the lines at
the camartage when she is
reasonable yeah i was being reasonable
like she's so threatening and then when
she starts unleashing yeah you don't
want to [ __ ] with her i think she's so
good it really she's incredible captured
the villain well she really felt like
scarlet witch like and and i really have
enjoyed her as wanda all these years but
she really felt like there's charlotte
witch here yeah and that is a different
character wonder visions wanda this is
scarlet witch yeah and i i really
enjoyed getting to see scarlet witch a
character that won when we met way back
in the age of ultron days i'd never
thought we'd get this actualized
obviously i never thought we'd get six
hours of building up wanda so that you
care about scarlet witch so much but she
is absolutely i think one of the mvps of
the mcu i think she should be in the
conversation with downey and with josh
brolin and like the the greats uh but
yeah she's the character we've gotten
the most time to grow with and that's
one of the reasons that my expectations
were very high and why i do have some of
the issues i do is because of how much i
love wanda and liz olson's portrayal
hells yeah koi and disney fan in the
main chat says koi is amazing up things
have turned we're not reading those
comments no just the hate not the plebes
tt
usd thank you so much appreciate you hey
guys do you feel fans and critics should
be more or less lenient when critiquing
mcu films multiverse amanda should have
been better in my opinion and i want
marvel to uh
and i want
to hold a higher standard uh but i can't
argue with box office numbers take that
away johnny
yeah uh uh uh i mean i don't think
i guess
my my cinema brain says no critics
shouldn't be any more lenient than they
are or aren't i mean i think you should
meet every movie for what it's trying to
accomplish but these are the biggest
most expensive most mainstream movies
and thus they should be held to a
standard
and people are fair to have their
expectations because these are
incredible undertakings of time and
resources and they are you know
characters built on tremendous history i
mean
yeah the what it means to be a comic
book movie i think is growing and
shifting all the time so i feel like the
expectations are hard to agree upon but
i can't really blame anybody for having
them again especially when all these
movies cost like hundreds of millions of
dollars
um so yeah i mean i i i would if
anything i guess i would encourage
people to be lenient in terms of when
they are trying new things out because
people bemoan the formula so
uh i feel like experiments should be
welcomed and at least viewed for their
potential even if they don't hit
necessarily the marks so that those
experiments could maybe be improved upon
moving forward but the marvel
producer team generally seems to be good
about those things anyway or have a kind
of keen eye for that so so that's the
only kind of leniency i would
encourage you know i think it's
interesting because this is an
unprecedented thing in movies where it's
effectively a tv show it's a series so
you're getting instead of you know half
an hour to an hour on your tv you're
getting two hours of the theater but
it's all serialized so what's hard to
critique and look at and experience here
is that you're critiquing the mcu in one
way and you're critiquing the movie in
another because you can't remove your
experience with the characters prior you
can't remove your association with
benedict cumberbatch and infinity war
and doctor strange one and those things
because it is one thing but it's also
its own thing so there is no uh standard
of criticism yet for this so while i
don't think there should be any more
lenient i do think that it needs to be
understood that you're not looking at
this like you're looking at an a24 film
you're not looking at this like you're
looking at even another kind of
blockbuster jurassic world fallen king
no the dominion is the sixth film in a
series and yes you can look at it as
compared to jurassic park but even that
was so long ago in so many different
realms of technology but at the end of
the day you're only comparing it to six
films this is the 34th
installment in the marvel cinematic
universe so it is uh yes and no as far
as leniency it's a different it's a
different thing altogether it's like
nothing else so far
i am i think that's fair i think that's
fair
um let's move on johnny
absolute vodka all righty
here we go thank you so much roberto
stewart oh what a super gracious super
chat i am tired 45 minutes dedicated to
your question
per minute that's right you can break it
down
i'm tired wanda being a victim of
circumstance why can't they just have
her be like shadow from sonic or thanos
doing terrible things because she wants
to that's better writing the darkhold
corrupting darkhold being why she's
insane as a cop-out oh smart way to
condense all the words in there that way
you can get it all in there for the
limited amount of characters you have in
a super chat uh you should put y and w
you gotta give credit where credit's due
um excellent have you guys ever given a
super chat you wouldn't know
it to me it demeans her grief all right
let's talk about this a little bit
shadow from sonic i want to stay on that
subject right now that sounds great
that's a one-to-one comparison right
there um yeah what i would say is that
i think i mean cory why don't you take
this one actually you kick it off so you
get off all now okay so i feel like you
need because of what i was just
describing the layers of nuance if you
just have her like shadow who's going to
be in one film then she's bad because
she's bad doesn't get to really have a
long going arc i think we know wanda too
well i think we've experienced wanda as
a good person for too long that if she
just switched it would feel like my
negatives with the film for me
personally where she just switches so i
do think you need
her grief and those things incorporated
but you also need more augmentation i
don't love the use of darkhold so i'm
agreeing with you there but i also don't
think that wanda is bad because she's
upset
works with
a lot of the issues with 70s comics and
a lot of the issues with um mad woman
syndrome and 80s films there's a lot of
negative connotations to uh like
actually let's talk about the amber
heard johnny depp trial uh there's an
there's an issue in that wherein they
brought in a therapist um to basically
say she's got a and i've not been
following that close but i've heard that
they brought in a therapist to uh say
she has a certain kind of mental illness
i don't remember what it is these are
people's personal lives i could give a
[ __ ] i hope they're happy and i hope
that everyone lands well they're
definitely happy but like there's it's
all landing well
but there's a type of mental illness i
don't i didn't follow the trial enough
but it basically was like hey she's got
this thing so she did it because she's
crazy i think that's a very dangerous
precedent and a very slippery slope
especially when it comes to people and
how americans view mental illness so i
think that the reason you need to add
the augmentation of things like mystical
elements and supernatural is not just
for the superhero at all but because
mental illness is very very
misunderstood in this country so having
someone just be angry or upset and
having them just go mad isn't
necessarily healthy for culture and
these movies reach millions of eyes so
the last thing you want is for people to
demean people with mental illness
well i think maybe there there's a
middle section here for what roboto
studios is actually getting at with it
which is
i think i think what it is is that they
just wanted her wants the desire for her
to like play just so much more into
she's just a full-blown villain but also
have what you're talking about like okay
but there's a an understanding and a
nuance to it instead of relying so
heavily on the the mournful side of her
and and the grieving side of her like i
personally find that more effective and
i prefer that layer of nuance and i
think we kind of want a little bit both
in the middle yeah i think i think we're
just like i just want her to go like
[ __ ] unleashed to the point where
you're like no you're bad like you're
you're bad now you want to get to that
point and then i think that's kind of
like how it felt for me with
a little bit with killmonger
kind of the desire i had would kill like
how i thought black panther's fulfilled
killmonger that
it sort of sneaks up on you how like
heartbreaking it is when he dies yeah
because you're like this dude's a bad
guy but then when he dies you're like oh
man that's [ __ ] hard but even papa
thanos got so much time to really
establish where he was coming from that
thanos was right is a is a meme like i
think that there's a perspective there
that is more than just grief well i
think that's my point is that thanos
you're still like he's the bad guy right
but when you break it down you're like
but i understand where he's coming he's
sitting the four or five lines and i
think we kind of wanted a little bit of
of that oh yeah no dude i mean i would
love for some time um i would snap away
50 percent 80 of them
there's no balance here right i'm here
for it i'm just i don't care just take
it one of us is gone to me to me it's
it's both i mean like to me i feel like
it's not just oh it's all the dark hold
it it's to me it's always been a
combination of wanda's grief then ex
extrapolated and exacerbated by the drug
that is the dark the dark goal is
feeding off of her grief and i don't
wanna not to buck the the order but
roboto actually did send a clarifier uh
saying to explain shadow lost maria so
he wanted humanity dead uh it's the
wrong thing to do but you understand it
i agree with koi they fast traveled to
scarlet witch and then copped out with
the dark hole being why she is so we're
saying the exact same thing okay yeah
yeah okay i'm glad there was a follow-up
because we were kind of long-forming
that yeah absolutely [ __ ] you up man
yeah lucky lucky i caught that yeah i
found out where you lived
take your money back
what a weird what a weird assault we'll
find your place and i'm going to give
you a refill we appreciate you for
agreeing with us
no just joking thank you thank you so
much all right oh we got some strem labs
yeah michael mack is in this way john no
let's be fair through one one we'll find
isolate one comment here all right let's
go to the bottom of the comments one one
of the actual
the i'll always complain i watch other
youtube channels i don't do it
hey
the thing i wanted was just more
expressing
a like of the movie but wishing that it
had more breathing
the brightness room
hopes that this helps the computer not
crash yeah oh is it is it
risking that happening oh no okay we've
got too many things running there's a
lot going on yeah all right
okay
there's a lot of great comments about it
i mean it's all reflective of what we've
got
yeah yeah yeah did wanda poop in
stephen's bed
yes
that was the best one yes
that was the best one all right
michael mack is in the stream we'll find
a good chat in a minute hey guys just
wanted and thank you michael mack uh hey
guys just wanted to say congratulations
on the views and growth of both uh your
channels over the past few months be uh
big love from scotland hey we all right
michael mack we just became scottish
lords so we're we're eating faster than
you realize
cole you get an established title with
us
he said he said both you guys i think
he's including your channel but i have
15k uh yesterday don't make this about
you he said both channels i mean shut up
boy is it both your channels i i i okay
this youtube channel and greg's
instagram
8 000 from a million you guys are around
the bend i just think and we need to
keep the focus focus right here right
here so excuse me i'm sorry for speaking
we're going to talk about koi jean
grove's youtube channel eight thousand
away growing tick tock boys andrew or
how your instagram at koi gendro you can
now do swipe cause that's been growing
very important how your twitter
following is about over time cars um
we don't need to talk about all the
success even just like that thank you
michael all right pandemic pj because
you have more usually the dollars have
more yep oh he's going for it oh they're
smart you smart dollars we got a
four-part block dollar phone all right
oh you guys roll i guess i'm in the
minority for this movie this is a top 10
mcu movie for me i love the visuals and
i absolutely love the score and the use
of silence in the movie yes when she's
in the mirror that's a great scene
i think trailers definitely reveal too
much but it didn't hurt the movie for me
let's go up now john
people who complained about it being
more of a raimi film rather than an mcu
movie annoy me they finally allow the
director to make a movie they want and
the audience doesn't appreciate it i
still feel like the studio sort of
interfered and been like cut her down uh
i loved it that it didn't follow the mcu
formula yes i agree and uh we are raymie
heads except for no koi coins you like
raymie yeah that's why i said people
that like graham you're gonna love it
and people like them mc you're gonna
like it hoping this hasn't been asked
because i believe it deserves a
discussion
but is one of the best villain we have
gotten in the mcu i think she gives
thanos a run for his money she was scary
it was an absolute force loved her as
the villain i think a villain has to be
as complimented
its weight of the villain is also
complemented by how
how good the movie itself is you know
what i mean yeah like thanos is such a
memorable villain because that those
movies are great are so like
like such an outstanding part of the mcu
yeah um i would say like uh i really
even though shangri is not one of my
favorites i still really love tony long
and that mandarin into that movie i
think she's one of the best yeah i think
for sure she's definitely one of the
best she's pretty great i think she
makes the mount rushmore villains watch
her and i'm just like man evil one is
[ __ ] hot i don't know what it is i
get it it's the evil it's a yeah it's
all that evil also like unresolved
mommy's mother day issues here we are on
mom's day but also like lizzie olson is
so good at being both maternal and
terrifying and i think that's a part of
it like and joking aside i do think
that's terrifying but terrifying is hot
but like there's there's a nest to
lizzie olsen's portrayal that like is so
special and i i never found
fano thanos is probably my favorite
villain but i also never um hot i never
found him hot which is very important
for my ability no but i i never uh i got
where he was coming from
memes to show you
thanos
no but that man wasn't going up there to
try to kill him
and feminine wanted to stay there for a
few hours that was a sunday in the
afternoon with ant-man and thanos
no but but i do find that i think about
scarlet witch's journey a little bit
more than thanos's journey so while i
can empathize with thanos and the thanos
was right meme concept i think scarlet
witch i could see where she's coming
from more as an individual so i can
objectively go like i see where thanos
is coming from but i can actually feel
scarlet witch's pain and therefore that
makes a really interesting villain so
she's in my rush i guess i just don't
view her like while she's the villain in
this movie i still don't view her as a
villain
overall no no overall that's that's why
i don't go there with you yeah because
she's one of my favorite characters in
the mcu for sure like i don't consider
loki villain anymore
and he was yeah yeah so kind of your
verse
killmonger thanos and scarlet which are
my three yeah i'd agree with that man i
really like mandarin a lot i really
really like the new ones when you say
that again all right bring this uh go
just more pj he's got one more finally
the reason uh i guess i know you're far
away so that's i'm not cutting you off
because i want to be the center of
attention and you're far away you'll
have to go stumble i understand john i
don't blame you the the text yeah
finally the reason this is a top 10 mcu
movie for me because the issues i have
with the movie are so
minor that it didn't affect my viewing i
thought some of the cgi was shoddy and
wong's long hair changed in the
beginning i always noticed hair
differences even in x2 x-men united
there was one sequence that just cuts
back and forth to wolverine i'm like his
hair's clearly
a haircut like why didn't
i asked about long's hair in an
interview yeah i remember that yeah yeah
and uh is there more john that's it
that's why that's his description of
like flev's next all right cool yeah
fair enough man i think that's fair
thank you guys who have contributed to
our stream laps too youtube's always
like we're taking eighty percent of your
money
that's i appreciate that
they're they're they're kind they are
but uh okay let's go here flavius doran
the pace was weird probably they thought
people won't like it too many three-hour
movies every year after the batman were
like we need to shorten this [ __ ]
president
can i make them all just
it was spiderman no way home we did it
with the turtles we gotta gotta slow it
down slow it down
but seeing how this was the tenth
biggest opening ever oh really 10 weeks
opening average i didn't know that
um wow that's really impressive yeah i'm
pleased i can't really argue that much
in that point we'll see what the
retention's like that's what i'm really
curious about see what the watch time is
on that movie chavez was okay but the
weakest of the new avengers lineup um is
there more from philip
i see a dot dot
john no i guess not
no no okay let's go back to what fluff
said then
um
what we're talking about
i do i did crave definitely more like
it's it could use another 20s 25 minutes
i think zochi gomez is a great actress i
sincerely i really mean that i think
she's great and she is charming like i i
liked her i didn't want her to die you
know like i cared about her um i care
about her just enough to give a [ __ ] you
know that's what caring about means
but i i did find that i would like to i
did crave more like just genuine
substance from her you know what i mean
not her performance the the writing and
the storytelling like that whole like
walking on the memory bank that i think
it's so
everything like guys this is the most
weird convenient plot i haven't never
seen a deus ex
plot like a little device
that gives you plots and and when
there's no device there's no awareness
there's no chewy yeah and i thought
michael waldron might bring that because
he's from rick and morty yeah but they
walked onto a plot device but it's so
serious that i'm like
this i think is the first time or one of
the the times where i've seen a movie
and really at least as it came across to
me felt like oh yeah i can tell that
some of this is from like a really well
worked out draft and some of this was
probably written later and didn't have a
chance to be reworked and that feels
definitely like one of those things and
two i just love that that scene
it says like you know remembering your
memories for a discount for like and
then
any
they can clearly see each other's
memories yeah and everyone is walking
around ignoring the dr strange is alive
and doing it
i mean they tried talking about bruce
campbell being like cool costume but
they're also like look at these crazy
memories of of
these
core memory setting yeah yeah why is it
those things why is it core trauma we
gotta go right into inside out i mean
american chavez i mean it's not strange
it's core memory trauma it's not the
watch
but it's it's but it's about a core
memory we haven't seen i know it's what
we need for the movie this movie
onto is background information we're not
going to do exposition until but and
also poor america chavez was like all
exposition like other than that scene we
don't really know anything about her
except for things that further the plot
but the way we got that scene how that
was introduced to us really undercut
mike's my experience of watching that
scene and it moves by so quick
you know especially in a movie with
people [ __ ] about the gay stuff i'm
like jesus christ there's like no it's
not even
at that point i'm like it's not even gay
things so it's just
mom's
son of a british there needs to be a dad
in the scene where is the dick like i
don't even notice the freaking gay pride
i didn't until the second video until
people pointed out i'm like oh it's
there yeah i noticed on the second
viewing because i saw the costume
earlier and i was like oh i see it in
person we're not trying to be like cool
defenders of this stuff i just don't
notice them the first time oh edgy um
stood up and was like
leaving this movie
won't go broke marvel
mentioned in passing how about how dare
you have a 15 second sequence with
parents i know you do two moms for
mother's day who do you think you are
yeah i i wanted america's chavez and
strange to have like a full-on personal
thing when that turn comes it's actually
motivated by anything especially in a
movie with uh multiple mind readers how
do you not just have a flashback why
isn't scarlet witch go like and like
understand where she comes from show
that scene why doesn't xavier go like i
mean what if scarlet witch came in and
was like i will take your power and send
you back to your parents anyway pandemic
jones we got a thing from you uh uh uh i
think uh you're back i think we're
re-watching this movie is up there uh
seriously loved it it was the first mcu
movie where the uh where i thought
anyone could die the kills were brutal
john krasinski's reid richards too made
me so happy i think i'm done now no love
guys no
no you already pledged to our patreon
you keep coming back here now yeah in
the stream laps yeah i'm gonna just
scroll up till i find you send us your
account number direct direct we we can
we'll just pull as needed
just like oh we need to get here
some questions we want to update the
quality of this we're trying to get a
deal with uh elgato or um uh [ __ ] uh
what's the other one clearly they want
to work with us
what a great ad what a great plug
logitech logitech i'm talking about that
so that way i could try we try to update
the quality of the streams um basically
because why would we pay for that
take your no we've already invested
money in stuff
like the really really crazy [ __ ] that
would be awesome um curtis mason
corey why don't you read it man curtis
mason love this guy i just saw doctor
strange's mom last night
i loved the film
i loved the build but i think it
suffered in a similar way to one
division there were too many predictions
and theories going in i think we all
assumed this movie would be more based
on rumors that didn't pay off i do think
we're living in an age where you know we
we enjoy theorizing but i also try to
check those expectations at the door as
best i can what's hard for me is when
they actually show it to us so like i
don't mind going like i wonder if blank
is in this i wonder if like for example
i really still loved no way home even
though it was all but revealed because
by the time the actual moment landed it
was so worth it and it my brain didn't
go like oh that was something i expected
in this they showed us those
five second clips in the trailer but
they were all in the movie for five
minutes so i was like the point of this
was a moment to feel as opposed to
norway home where they had full
characterizations and arcs so that that
the illuminati were cameos it really was
undermined by expectations for me
personally uh i didn't need more cameos
i didn't need more of those things i
just wanted more time to flesh out wanda
to maybe see another multiverse so it
felt multiversal but like i i'm with you
curtis i'm surprised feige doesn't have
more control over the direct marketing i
am too like the fact because he has to
come out and say that he came out and
said you know the trailer showed too
much
yeah like does he not sign off on i
thought he would i thought he would be
the one to go don't do that yeah you
know
but
this is the only thing getting people to
heaven these days is
being good so the only thing keeping us
going
hey but it worked it's the 10th biggest
opening of all time
nickel mick michael mark is back
when murder drugs strange why didn't his
cloak slap the [ __ ] out of him
he's the scottish guy right yep was that
clock secretly taking sips of that drug
tea
does clock have a drug problem
do we need an intervention for a cloak
am i focusing on this too much not
enough no ma'am never enough that
bothered me i missed some of cloaks
personality yeah that's such a charming
part of the first doctor strange and i
like even in what if when his cloak was
about to die i'm like no and like the
cloak stuff with spider-man and what if
like there's a lot of cloak and yeah
when he fell to the ground i was like
that he wouldn't fall did he he ever
healed the cloak uh yeah he got blue
patron christine christine patched it in
oh yeah yeah yeah but like
i definitely felt that was lacking too
the cloak was an important character in
the first yeah but it lost they kept the
personality of the cloak in the
beginning when it's like wake up strange
you know when he's knocked out
and when it wipes his face and he pukes
yeah yeah but then after that it was
just okay it was just cape
yeah all right you're a cloak now yeah i
like the person maybe they patched away
his personality maybe that patch was
just
all over his heart
killed she was trying to help kill her
off in every universe i love i love
rachel mckay too i thought she was so
much better in this she had more
versions she's so good in this i'd love
to i really appreciate it i'm going to
go with 20 seconds
uh i really appreciate christine palmer
and dr strange in this film when they
have that final scene together of
i think they're acting as top notch in
that scene when when they
are they know they're not the same
strange and palmer but there is this
love and yearning just in the presence
of one another and like the love you on
every universe line is so powerful yeah
you can tell she feels it too and she's
like i am compelled i'm drawn to want to
go along with you but yeah i think
that's such a great such a great scene
between them and and that scene out does
anything between her and
doctor strange and the first doctor
strange movie for me yeah and i i really
like that they gave her science like
they gave her things to do like they
like she had purpose now that i gave
that compliment and the wedding scene
when she's first talking to strange
she's got this big mole like a robert de
niro mall thingy oh yeah i was wondering
if you would know that
[Laughter]
i noticed it because i was like i wonder
if greg would notice that and then when
i watched the dark knight ten times on
imax and it was like what's with that
big pimple by christian palestine i
always notice these like the things that
stand out on you know greg doesn't like
skin things i mean i'm just saying you
got millions of dollars you know unless
there's it's gonna get imax cameras are
gonna notice
that's true all that extra definition
uh we got it because she's beautiful as
hell i think she's i mean she's stunning
yeah i would i would i would like
literally melt like fantastic dudes are
fantastic john saw me fall madly in love
at the premiere with it's good that i
wasn't more involved it's good that i
wasn't more involved i literally fell in
love like yeah it was it was i was i was
flummoxed i was flabbergasted i was i
was a puddle man haley atwell is
she was so sweet and kind and we talked
it like i just melted like she is a
darling this is why i don't go off
tangent because then it starts because
now here we are
i wasn't bothered with the illuminati
because for a cameo they were good john
krasinski and patrick stewart got loud
ovations in my theater which is rare for
a reserved romanian audience uh wanda is
so
sexual as romanian
officially my favorite mcu character
overall the film's good it was a complex
combination of bad editing bad promotion
let me tell you why this film's good
big expectations built because of the
many great fcu flicks from recent years
probably the third best strange flick
after what if yet i still had fun i just
wanted more i i share that sentiment
with you i'm like i like everything here
i just wanted more and maybe that more
could have fleshed out the couple like
technical gripes that i had you know
yeah yeah for sure everything's good
just expand it
just expand it i also do feel like we've
we've been living in a really
specifically good age of movies lately
with everything everywhere all at once
the unbearable weight of massive talent
like there's so much good multiversal
stuff to to have a movie that doesn't
let you live with some of those beats it
did feel you know don't don't talk about
everything i'm going to react to that on
the channel oh yeah john already saw it
oh dude i i cannot wait to see it again
yeah i've seen it twice already i love
it
it's probably like in in the last 10
years one of my it's one of my favorite
movies of all time but maybe my favorite
in the last five years and if you yeah
no absolutely and if you want to see if
you feel like you didn't get enough
multiverse go watch that movie
go watch that 15 million dollar maybe
this movie lets you down because you
already saw everything everywhere all at
once
maybe you compared it maybe i want to
see doctor strange do his texts i'd like
to see
i mean like the scientists got to be a
very telling soho's expensive land
telling me
i didn't see the trailers either yeah
yeah i avoided them because i'm a big
daniels i knew daniels was doing it i'm
just like
daniel's and michelle yo i'm there yep
also a quick comment from the regular
chat the j shay rae strange's beer is
really inconsistent from scene to scene
i've noticed his beard and his hair are
they have a mind of their own across
every strange exclusive property i don't
know that there's ever a hairpiece that
looks like hair it always looks yeah
like it's been cl like like helmeted on
yeah it's like it's lego hair it's like
a bit of a cover match has hair yeah
i've seen it wow we've got a lot of
super chats i was not aware
yeah you always have to get yeah you're
always confused
before this you're like guys we have a
heart out we have an exact time that is
actually a half hour
otherwise we'd be here for six hours and
we'd love that and i zoom back in i've
got other things okay meander more we
left off with roboto studios by the way
for playback purposes this will be i
forgot to mention this at the top this
will be uploaded to our podcast thank
you yes yeah and if you could go ahead
and find us and and follow on spotify uh
apple podcast anywhere you get your
podcast search real rejects even just
following really helps us out and uh
that's gonna be growing in the to the
future so yeah please go find us there
if you enjoy our banter at all pop
culture podcast spencer
good to see you again thought i'd come
and contribute to your channel and your
chat got to be at work soon so i won't
be able to watch all of this live
unfortunately so you aren't even here
for this reading are you but you can
listen to it on the podcast which you
can subscribe to and support these guys
he already supports us on patreon thanks
pcp thank you for your patron who comes
in here and and extra kindness that's
insane and hey go go check out uh
especially responsible i'll say go check
out spencer's podcast too pop culture
podcast greg and i have both done
episodes with him uh is deadshot 254
thank you from europe many people say
how vision doesn't seem to be present if
ultron bots exist and he is good
then what reason would there be for
vision to exist we see this is where my
question came in with vision was that if
vision is present wouldn't that mean
i mean uh ultron is present
an ultron bots exist wouldn't tony stark
have had to exist at one point in this
universe too an iron man to have created
ultron
yes and so what happened to him where is
vision who was wanda's husband yeah to
have does she make these children and
they just they actually became you know
i think they're real children fine like
sentient finite things yeah i don't live
in a hex i think in that universe maybe
it's not vision who she marries and that
that's you know a variation because you
know it's just a regular paul bennett
just just paul paul betty the actor yep
paul actor paul betting texting johnny
breaking up
getting getting
somehow cycling back but i do think the
the tony stark of it
but the paul bettany
my wife's a witch should we burn her
[Laughter]
in cannon yep
uh but i do think tony stark might have
been the seventh chair
i do think it was him yeah and then tom
cruise pissed him off he tried
recruiting scientologists on set it's
just a whole problem
he wanted the xenu uh cinematic universe
introduced but i can't imagine you film
a scene with tom cruise and cut it like
that like why would you do it he was
like i want to be in the action yeah i
want to be in the actual iron man suit
and i want to actually be flying and
doing the scene yeah he's like i will
only do my own stunts
this isn't real technology and we can't
do that this is real technology only do
it if it's real technology if we can
build this technology yeah jumping
do my own stunts and then we'll recast
him with terence howard i want
christopher mccord to rewrite this whole
screenplay
brendan v thanks for chiming in
someone said i think
maggie brooks said i think reed made the
ultron bots they worked because he's the
smartest i guess there is a there's an
option of reed to be the one that
invented them and then they could have
said that they could have how do you
like my old trump butts
dr strange doctor strange before we
begin your tribe what did you think of
my own what did you think i know you've
seen something i know you're smart what
are these compare i know you you weren't
around for ultron but
uh and but there has to be a tony stark
it's a multiverse there's gotta be an
iron man there unless it's one of the
few that doesn't have a tony stark i
mean technically the only characters
that are in every universe that look the
same are nexus beings and he's not a
nexus being but theoretically there
would be a variation of that important
of a figure in the universe yeah so he
would probably look different a lot tom
cruise mel gibson everyone loves him
audrey
thank you love
your guys's channel who
especially koi zhandra ooh where do you
see them taking juana's characters next
she's not dead i'm in denial she's not
dead she's not dead they didn't show her
body she's too she's too much of a
valuable property also they didn't show
her body and they showed captain
marvel's body they showed everybody
else's body if they were dead dead and
in comic books that's more of a i think
when you're a pickup legacy character in
the mcu if the actor wants to leave it
has to be some type of like sacrificial
payoff
yeah you know they have that yeah i'd
like to leave us a good point you know i
am scarlet witch
the
anytime a character wants to leave we
have to flash to a multiverse where it's
their snapping
way out that's the big uh where her
character goes next i imagine a bit of a
bucky barnes path
in the in the sense of
vibranium children no she's
vibranium therapy the red wolf
i guess i guess the tone of it being
like she's gonna be isolated like it's
gonna be like like on her own and
probably having to live
like very like kind of where she where
we thought we might be seeing a little
bit of her in this movie but didn't um
but i think trying to have a life like
that or maybe she just tried to get
accepted back into the lunch box
yeah that's her first thing i want back
on the lunch box i need money maybe she
goes on to maybe i can produce anything
but money at that time
she goes on a giant walkabout meets a
guy that cares about it turns out to be
her dad his name's eric
actually you know that's a great thing
that maybe they would reserve
her for her for when
they really finally tied the x-men into
i i'd have her meet her dad and i'd i'd
bring that whole like existential crisis
of like the miracle children and the
word mutants because eventually we do
want the no more mutants so i personally
would bring in eric lyncher uh with her
i do think it would have been a much
more powerful choice if
they were like a strange is here it's an
incursion yeah um and then and the
illuminati seeding was about trying to
stop scarlet witch
i think that would have been just a more
focused powerful choice and especially
with like discussion of mutants with
xavier i would have loved to have heard
the word mutant from xavier in the
context of scarlet witch and then it
would be like wait is she a mutant in
some universes it would have been like a
lot bigger of a question yeah yeah
something that would be more intriguing
so literally i watched in my video four
months ago but i thought they would i
really thought they were gonna literally
read read discussing the science and
maybe ultron and then captain marvel
discussing like her power set and
keeping the arrogance and keeping her as
interesting as that argus she's the most
interesting black bolt i think did what
he could and then xavier saying mutants
like just those little changes would
have made that whole setup more of a
thing of substance yeah and make it
still really just focus still contained
because you they don't seem to be
they're like yeah we don't even worry
about juana it's about you you're the
problem strange and like i like that for
the end arc of him being like you know
uh unique amongst the strangest but
there's so many other ways to tell that
story yeah
kisume in the chat says that franklin
richard should have a revenge arc since
wanda killed his dad that's why we can
see wanda in the future
oh played by jayden smith played by
jayden smith who's also in the chat uh
jaden i'm not even kidding not probably
not the real one but there is a james
smith in the chat jacob azin uh what if
hahaha this movie sets up franklin
richards
marvel multiversal big bad for losing
his father to a witch from another
universe
i didn't read those together so uh coy
before we proceed why don't you tell the
audience about the son of reed richards
so franklin richards is an all-powerful
being almost a omega-level mutant level
being uh and he is a
character that can basically invent
universes what's interesting about him
is it's kind of it seems like it's
finite so right now in the comic books
he's actually de-powered he does not
have the ability to make these universes
so what's fun there is it's a fish out
of water story where all the rest of his
family have powers and franklin richards
like i used to be a god and now i'm just
a 12 year old uh so the kid's like
trying to rebuild his sense of self and
the sense of self-worth while everyone
around him has all these powers and
franklin richards is a really cool um
kind of inverse to the apocalypse into
onslaught storyline wherein xavier and
magneto both formed one being of all
powerful uh destruction called onslaught
that destroyed the entire marvel
universe that caused characters to be
reborn in this very um polarizing
character arc called heroes reborn and
in that the idea of franklin was
incepted and then all these years later
we have him be a creature of creation
versus destruction mirroring the 90s
versus the 2020s of comic books as a
character
you bring value to the live stream i
tried to give you some knowledge here
and there
does that answer a question that was
beautiful that does answer my question
and to answer your question that would
work that would work
after my 30 years of comic dissertation
yes and i think you might have skipped
one there was two down i thought
something about a not yeah right the did
we say the true not no we did not i got
you oh it looks like we missed a few
no no just one just the one just one
uh
i think i read brendan v's name off and
maybe we got cut off then we just got
sidetracked i appreciate you yeah yeah
brendan v all right extra love extra
love to brendon v brendan v has been in
these chats and following along with us
and and been a good you know a cool dude
back and forth you know we've chatted so
much love to brendan v no shade bruh we
want to save you for a minute wanda
versus the true not from dr sleep who
would win probably what is this what's
the true nut uh it's the rebecca
ferguson cult who's stealing the uh you
know shine from the kids oh my god no
juana would
later i mean
rebecca ferguson all day every day bring
her to the mcu let's do this love evil
women
you really do
rebecca
deserve to be evil sometimes i've always
found her attractive but she's the
hottest in doctors men are evil always
women deserve to have some fun the carny
wardrobe and the hat and the evil man
rebecca ferguson super like insanely
strong quad i love it yeah and then i
would love to see that match up please
she gets her ass whooped by that little
girl in that movie yeah yeah juan is
taking her out wanda's gonna wreck
everything yeah man like as much as i
would love to see it and as much as i
love she wanted to fight off the ghosts
and at the end of doctor strange yeah
they stopped bothering her
rebecca ferguson that movie like oh my
god
oh hey from patreon what's up uh hey did
you uh john oh hey this one's hey let me
read it to you yes john yes john i got a
question for you
i got a question for you did you feel
like your experience specifically you
john with the darkhold in aos that's
agents of shield john may digesting
wanda's turn john a little easier john
yeah all my aos friends saw john this
coming john yeah yeah yeah absolutely i
mean really use those characters to get
drawn in there a lot i i really
appreciated uh you know especially for
me those are a few
the things i've picked up from agents of
shield you know koi is the comic book
expert greg's read more comics than i
have that's my claim to fame yep i'm not
an expert i just have one up on john
i mean you're an expert too mccoy is the
bigger expert than both of us i'm
definitely not an expert uh and so yeah
franklin richards yeah that no i mean
like you say franklin is like i know the
son of reed richards
the details
yeah i mean that for me is just like a
fun thing of like oh yeah like i have
gotten to see this play out in a sense
and i i do appreciate i mean the
redesign that they did because the uh
agents of shield darkhold
has like this dueling ds design on the
cover and whatnot but anyway like i i do
i did enjoy getting that primer and it's
funny watching agents of shield and
continuing that journey i'm in season
seven right now uh has been very
fascinating because it coincides i think
better with the mcu now than it did
before but that's interesting they're
dealing with at the point in the show
that i'm at they're dealing with time
and they're dealing with uh you know
ripples in time and causality and
anyway but yeah the dark hole factoring
in and like uh uh ghostwriter and all
that stuff uh yeah like i thought that
was definitely uh you know a nice primer
and something that if you've seen it you
know it gives you more of that flesh to
maybe then extrapolate like okay here's
the effect it's having on wanda and why
and i feel like if you might not have
either read about the dark hole in the
comics or seen agents of healed
you can infer that but it just makes it
like way richer of an experience it's
just like not watching one division like
you can kind of but like it helps you
really understand yeah yeah and i i've
really like agents of shield was a show
that that from the outside and from
having caught episodes out of context i
was always like uh you know whatever i
could take or leave and and jumping into
that show has been such a joy and it's
been really nice way of expanding the
mcu experience even though the mcu does
not recognize it at all
so yeah very grateful for the uh dark
hold experiences coming into this movie
gabriel bartholomew
your thoughts on john krasinsk as reid
ricardo i thought this would be the one
we had a hundred of today this is
actually like the first one directly
asking um
i think that there's a reason we've been
fan casting him forever i do feel like
we didn't get enough time with him to
really have him feel like anything but
like oh my god john krazinski uh i had
the same thing with greg where i was
like
i've never seen a scene in a movie that
felt so photoshopped because of my
memories yeah i've never been watching
something like i've seen this before but
i've never seen this before well two
though i think you have because
i mean while they might have put him in
a suit like part of me is pretty sus
i expect that they cgi'd a suit and his
head is on it oh it's very much like
that's the image we've seen online so uh
but like i i think he definitely in the
comic books they've been drawing him
more and more like john krasinski so
i've been kind of waiting for this
because they sometimes do that there's
one drawing in a comic that was like two
years ago that literally is a a cover uh
i think was gq or something that is just
john krasinski as richards and i was
like well that's a thing that's
happening uh so i've been looking
forward to it and then i think john
krasinski is one of the more
he he's got a lot of depth and he reads
as intelligent but there's also
something very like that guy could be a
dick if i could see that turn reed needs
to be a really good dude that you could
see being a dick whereas tony and
i would argue benedict are [ __ ] that
do good things like they their arc is
going the other way whereas reed i think
is coming from a place of good and
family but he's so wrapped up in his
science and he's so wrapped up in trying
to save the world through here that he
forgets everything around him and i get
that from john krasinski i could see him
getting so overwhelmed in his hyper
focus that it comes across as arrogance
where he's not actually as arrogant as
your benedict or tony so i think it's
really important to cast read well and i
think he'd be excellent but i didn't get
to see it yet doesn't read go down a
villainous path at times he does uh in
the comic books especially the ultimate
universe which a lot of the marvel films
are based off of uh in the ultimate
fantastic four he turns into a full-on
villain wherein he tries to expand his
mind to such a level he starts taking
like hormones and growth things and he
grows this mound of brains through the
back of his head and has to wear this
special helmet where he kind of looks
like a brood um but he's a full-on
villain uh called ultimatum in that
universe and that character is one of
the only characters from the ultimate
universe to survive an incursion event
which is something you see happen in
this film where in the comic books the
incursion event is the actual physical
planets colliding and the only way to
stop it is to basically explode the
physical and life forms on that planet
so the uh illuminati in that world is
composed of all different heroes in all
these multiverses deciding the merits of
their universe versus others so they're
having to to juggle the uh great
quandary of life of like is my life
worth more than others on the planetary
scale making for a very interesting
storyline check out um new avengers uh
right after the bendis run check out
secret wars about all of these things
and then check out ultimatum era
ultimates for the fantastic four stuff i
just talked about
so
guys
we gotta ask a question in the chat
there will be a test at the end of it
also that ivan ruiz comment was a big
thing that bothered me yeah i've
actually been saving that uh uh really
quick i ivan ruiz said they completely
ditched the idea in the end credits of
one vision of her hearing her kids
scream for help
yeah yep look guys sean we gotta change
this question all right we are ending
this poll
coin i have talked about possibly doing
this once uh i'm not gonna say where i'm
moving to
down
yeah because everyone knows where i live
now but i mean you know i don't know
um but we're talking about maybe uh
doing a figuring out maybe a show for
koi to do here and we're talking about
maybe doing some type of like
comic book based live show
and john form a question that asked if
we should do that be weekly i wanted
like something like ties into the movies
yeah that was the calm stuff
most of what i read i go
koi
uh i need to read some dr strange comics
and then so i read oath because of him i
read like the moon night one the the
thor com everything like a lot of what i
read often comes from like coy's
recommendations because he obviously
knows [ __ ] off the dome and whereas like
i need to freshen my head but it's also
hard to research like what to read
before the movie like a lot it's really
hard to know but i'm able to
contextualize and yeah
i've been thinking about some like uh
some show idea of how to like kind of
work work it a little bit where it could
be something that's like also involving
theories and yeah and things like that
because i think like i don't know it'd
be fun to do i don't want to make you
eric vos
you just want us to fight i like the off
the dome quality yeah i i do enjoy you
challenging me to a nerd off in public
at dr stranger he's like you guys have
to fight
all right cool and then i'll read the
next question while john's doing that um
hey guys
uh aiden thank you hey guys enjoy the
keep releasing this mike's like
differently positioned um no you're good
it's facing your mouth hey guys enjoy
the content as always i like this movie
a lot i really enjoyed wanda in this
film a lot i love that they killed the
illuminati off i kind of wanted them to
die during
higgins just gotta
show up and you're like take them out
these guys are [ __ ] annoying i don't
want him i hope wanda
his cameos are [ __ ] i know this movie be
over sooner
um
yeah i was hoping she would kill them
off too i i really i think black bolt
dying the way it did is fine because
black bolt already got to have a scene
where he killed strange and there's not
much she could really do with his powers
you know what i mean yeah like once you
just like have a talk off with it it's
just like dodging it left and right
so yeah but i think reed richards it
would have been nice to have seen him
actually do some fighting or have a
longer debate about it yeah but that
exchange or wanna just throws oh that
[ __ ] line that wanda has oh my god
what when when your kids i have a i have
i have a family to do do they have a
mother yes
what does she say then your kids won't
be orphaned
they'll have someone to watch them or
something but the word orphans there's
gotta be someone around to raise them
it's gonna be like
i'm going to kill you
oh my god that was such a badass
but it would have been more rewarding if
there was a little bit of a fight i
would like to see reid like especially
because this is the first time we're
getting mr fantastic in the mcu it just
feels like it would have been everyone
else would've seen a version of yeah and
it would have been
truly reward even it would have been
truly rewarding it kind of undercuts mr
fantastic a tad bit for me if he just
gets kind of like his ass whooped so
easily and like when we see him again
when we meet him we've already met him
like we will never have that first john
cruz especially if they keep him we'll
never have that first time kristin's
getting screwed richard's moment where
it's got weight again yeah because we've
have we've had it he'll have a he'll
shave he'll shave he'll shave even
though krazynski's post office thing has
been beard i'm beard man i'm beard man
even though the comics reed has had a
beard for a while he'll shave and then
the comical shape too yeah
whatever the actors do we're gonna we're
gonna shave them people are only reading
us again because of the movie
i wanted to do like a period piece like
60s fish out of water fantastic four
like i think it'd be really cool to have
like you know the clean cut america's uh
you know americana marvel's first family
you know flavor so we'll see i am all
white i am hoping that one of the
upcoming
titles does go back period again i miss
that captain america what you can do is
you have that like the quantum realm you
have that world they showed in the
quantum realm that we've teased like
what if they're trapped in time like
what if reed was exploring the quantum
realm got stuck there so they're from
the 60s and they come out in a modern
day yeah i like this idea i just got i
want i just got it this is what i sold
zeros
we're gonna get you a headset
jess data graphic killing is something i
needed in the mcu and we need an r-rated
like this is time we're we're almost
there yeah like moon knight had some
moments that pushed it this pushed it
the furthest this had blood like that
one shot of carter's shield hitting the
pillar after halfing her there's blood
like ripping off yeah so smart to to
drench her in an ultron oil yes because
it was blooded because the way they
color it makes it look like she's just
drenched in blood he's like a toilet i
guess that willy's wonderland
yeah because it's it works on the plays
on the mind because i would forget that
it's just blood yeah and it's it's
brilliant in that capacity no they were
very clever of those little like ways
being like pg-13 looking like bolt's
head exploding that is brutal that's
like genuinely like i oh yeah and every
time you watch it everyone in the
audience like i just saw that like it's
a moment i was late to learning because
we watched the new rockstars breakdown
already and they slowed it down i didn't
i was i did not notice this both times i
watch it i thought juana just imploded
his head no he yells yeah i didn't catch
up oh yeah on that yeah i for i totally
missed everyone knows that but me i'm
stupid
hey you told me all about the ice scene
that i didn't pick up on it's called
character nuance you know actual writing
not cause cool bam bam visuals
yana
eternals fan absolutely hate wanda's
character assassination you and koi
should just have some drinks
at islands in bourbon
[Music]
all righty
pineapple burger islands
because it's date one it is delicious
hold on guys darkness
uh yeah
um
i i don't i can't fault someone for
feeling like they assassinated her
character
it's okay
you know what it is though too and this
is what i really
i haven't even considered until this
very moment
is
we all know that scarlet witch
eventually goes down badass [ __ ] path
right yeah we all know that
and uh i love that about her
in the comics and i love elizabeth olsen
just a beautiful performer
but if if an audience member doesn't
know that from the comics what that must
have been probably especially jarring
him yeah and the trailers don't
define that they only hint that maybe
she's doing some dark [ __ ] which i liked
otherwise um but especially if you've
just watched wanda vision
and then you watch this
i can imagine that for people who just
really had no idea
that that they do that in the comics
that she's that they're like oh my god
that's the step seven eight i was
talking about this is not flowing yeah
but for me i'm like no i expected them
to go there but i i want the movies to
be their own they're their own universe
so they need to be self-sustained yeah
man dude she's she's so bad so bad i
love her uh reynaldo torres i just
wanted to say i hope you guys know how
inspirational koi is
roy is the best and you guys should
learn a lot more from him
um you guys though suck
give all this to koi for all the late
nights you guys been editing and
reacting i gotta shout out the prepper
boys too they're helping us edit
constantly too if uh you know it's it is
a lot of editing and reacting late at
night
the life of a reactor
in the darkness sorry
when normally at 3am if we're watching
something i'm just like
that's all and then i play nirvana
everything internally
it's not showing by tonight you got to
let it out man
you inspire us to strive beyond the wall
that holds us back that is that's a
great line i don't know if i could
inspire us to strive beyond the wall
that holds me back
we saved a life here hey the wall that
holds them back you guys break down
what you've
done the way you watch television is
inspiring the way you talk about movies
is awesome
these guys earn their islands gift cards
every week this is called deflecting
this is called gratitude through
deflection
juan
but i'm going to use it in an argument
when i'm negotiating for a product
replacement that's smart you know what
we do
el gato
we inspire people to strive beyond the
walls and hold them back we use your
capture cards elgato we have two of them
i would like a logitech cameras to
strive beyond the wall that we're
already striving beyond
thank you reynaldo that means a lot juan
hernandez toby mcguire's dick i feel
like multiverse madness
i feel like multiverse madison did
everything that wanda went through in
her show even location wise with the
heezy well that's what that's what i'm
i'm glad i came to that one process at
this point i think that's the problem is
when
i didn't even realize i'm already
throwing in my comic knowledge right in
there
and not thinking in terms of
transition from show to film because i
think it's still there i think you fill
in the blank and i did treat it like
when you do a time jump in a show
um but i it does i i can especially see
that it's like too much like we should
have
watched her descend yeah yeah like and
so i agree with that i would have loved
to have god in that and i do feel that
it it works better for me on the second
viewing on the first viewing it is like
oh you're just like the wicked witch
right now yeah and like we we've not
done that with any other for arcs like
when we met her she was conflicted and
then she went through a giant arc and
then they i just feel like they rushed
into the third act of her journey yeah
and and that's not wanda i i don't know
so i i'm with you and also like they
implied that where she moved was mount
wondergore in in scarlet witch the sh i
mean in one division the show and then
to make one wonder gore a different
location in universe and like all those
things so yeah the things bothered me
what i was telling john the other day
was i think i might assist in the new
rockstars breakdown i'll probably go
tomorrow guys um was that i think it
would be cool for for multiverse of
madness if they did some type of like
clone wars type of show that like fills
in the blank for a lot of this because
going off of the next question here
especially like with wanda yeah seeing
some of that some of those scenes like
like like a clone wars thing being that
you it's like clone wars takes place in
between episode two and three and i
think doing something like that for here
to fill in the blanks not not what if
just something that expands this out it
flushes it out but like with cart kartik
sharma is saying i love this if you
count being dusted off as dying doctor
strange died three times in multiverse
of madness uh if 14 million 605 times
times infinity war 17 times in the first
doctor's range that's an awesome math i
love this statistic but my what this
reminded me of is the whole thing with
strange being blamed for doing the
dusting yeah and and to me i'm like that
would be such a great
character nuance to explore of like not
being appreciated for his part and
saving the world yeah you know and
especially the guilty carries and the
arrogance he carries yeah that like no i
did the right thing like look we're all
back most of us not your cats but most
of us are bad now your brother like that
that is such a fascinating dusted
experience that michael stoolbart was
talking about
when
like while he was gone his brother died
and he wasn't there for that and he
blames strange for it you know and he
can't like explain it you know i think
that is a great nuance that i would have
loved to have
would have
that would have been nice to just make
this part of the theme morbid and then
the continuing of that guilt with going
to other universes and realizing you're
a monster like then yeah not only are
you not getting credit for being a hero
but then going to a multiverse meaning
like wait i'm the problem like i really
like dr strange's um decreasing
vulnerability and softness in this film
i
i something that i constantly talk about
people is
really defined strange's arc for me in
this film it's and i feel like people
come sometimes have to
like use their mind to really like
pinpoint stuff yeah of like well there's
like beats here like he okay he learns
to not sacrifice people
he learns you know he he
bows to wong in the end he let's go with
a knife he let's go the knife he becomes
vulnerable you know um
but i think there was still some type of
emotional impact that was really missing
from the film in terms of the the
strange arc that just lands a punch like
really strong there's there's something
that was there and i feel like what
we're talking about
with you know like
really contemplating that that thing of
maybe i didn't do the right thing yeah
he's like and hopping through the multi
verses seeing reflections of himself and
like really letting the weight of that
be felt was something that
somehow it just doesn't quite get there
for me it's like like i see it there i'm
just not i can't it's not even that i
don't have that feeling i feel like
there needed to be a little bit more to
really just have it be so apparent and
more of
you know in the in the fields it kind of
oops i feel it in benedict cumberbatch's
performance
and yeah he knows he knows what it is
yeah it's evident by that so i feel like
there's a part of that arc that that at
least like emotionally
hits for me but i absolutely agree it
would have been nice to have like an
actual character examination that
doesn't feel like it's happening kind of
off screen or in between moments that
we're actually getting to see because i
feel like the the scene at the end when
he dismisses the the he's about to get
his third eye like the scene where he's
like you just did this and this and this
is like i'm fine
that is him saying i'm fine but
obviously not being yeah i feel like
they kind of did the same thing with him
meeting other strangers like where he
just dismissed it but we never got to
see like we got a visual of clearly he's
not fine we didn't get the equivalent of
the emotional i've met a bunch of me's
and they're not great like we didn't get
to feel that really well yeah and i mean
in the original movie
in the original movie too you at least
get to see
part of that first act of seeing him
struggle with the loss of his you know
uh uh hand mobility and everything like
that and you feel this the anguish of
that and so yeah it would have been nice
to feel some kind of emotional
confrontation
anguish
that's why
we gotta keep each other accountable to
talk to the camera and a part of that is
keeping our voices locked into the mind
here we are listen to these back later
i'm like when koi's turning i'm like no
dude you sound far away
we all need we always take the mic off
the arm and hold it i mean like no no no
that's going to tire your shoulder out
that's true these strong shoulders
and the traps
keep it going i love it my problem was
how they handled wanda and chavez at the
end and it felt forced to feel like she
should have learned her powers in the
holding cell
i definitely had a moment of of you know
and that's something phase one marvel
used to do and like earlier comic book
films where it was like i can't do this
i can't do this i can't do this i can do
this it would have been nice to see a
progression of her learning her skills
instead of like yo i know how to punch a
multi-verse like it was a very quick
learning curve oh he gave me the knife i
know how to use the knife i would have
liked to see the development a little
bit more like all of my biggest problems
with the film can be solved in like 20
minutes i just i could have used another
20.
the music fight was embarrassing and bad
oh my god devon yeah that was one of my
favorite moments that was one of my
favorites too yeah like such a cool
union of director and and long time
composer yeah but what a i think that's
such a great joy for the composer to be
involved in something where like the
music is the point of it because i love
how it starts off where
he like lands on the piano and it seems
like such a corny like cliche yeah yeah
and it seems like a tongue-in-cheek joke
but then it turns into like a weapon
to use the music notes as weapons and
the way how
the the john actually i think johnny
could probably talk a little bit more
about you're the music guy so why don't
you talk about it well yeah i mean i i
just personally love how it evolves over
time because yeah you get that piano
strike that dissonant strike that we
hear two or three times prior
uh like especially like when wanda's
looking at herself in the window there's
that classic horror movie sam remy
strike and then you had to have it grow
into this thing that it first starts out
just
to my ear sounding like you know
disparate notes and score music then
becomes like toccata and fugue
expresses the imagination and the
weirdness i feel like that's something
that people haven't talked about as much
and i've heard a couple people say and
that the movie could have been weirder
and stranger and more sort of out there
in terms of uh what happens and i feel
like that's one of those things where
i'm like wow i never would have thought
of that and i never would have thought
of you know using sound frequency i mean
it is you know beams and you know power
blasts too but you know i interpret it
as sound frequency also as weaponry um
and yeah it's just such a wonderful
moment because
it's quintessentially filmmaking you
know it's it's combining all these
elements together in a way that kind of
breaks the fourth wall because it's
directly calling attention to the
musical score and using it not even in a
mickey mousing kind of way but as a
literal prop to the scene uh so yeah it
contextualizes that whole interplay of
sound and visual in a really fun and and
lively way and then if you care about
the union of sam raimi and uh danny
elfman it's that much more special
because then you're like yeah like these
two like that feels like a victory lap
you know for them yeah i love that and i
it showed me what we could do with these
powers and as opposed to just like pew
pew so i dug it
yeah yeah sure so true and i was never
embarrassed
but we love you devon henderson we're
not embarrassed by
the everything everywhere nerd all the
time uh as soon as i heard the baxter
foundation i knew we were gonna get uh
sea reed so excited that it was krasinsk
that was a good way to set us up i loved
hearing it like the first time she said
backstage i was like oh are the rumors
true
like it took me three seconds to get
there like baxter found it the crowd was
reacting i was like oh baxter
yeah that audience was was solid at the
premiere but also there were some times
i was like these are movie fans like
there was like comic moments like the
baxter it took like one round of
laughter and then people being like oh
laughter and like listening and then you
get the second wave i mean earth 616 was
so cool that was awesome that was such a
moment surprise more surprised how many
people like picked it i got our opening
night screening no one cared
an imax no no no one even mattered an
eye the fan event at the lcat people
lost their minds that was one of the
bigger cheers because there's people
that have waited in line all day and
people just pulled their pants out and
[ __ ] yeah
screening of madness
everyone lost their minds crazy
matt b that's actually they used to
advertise old camp movies that way like
there are seven sequences of terror and
even one of them will cause you to lose
your mind sign a waiver in the lobby
i've seen that like chuck pollonic when
he reads guts and people fainting and
they're like we've had 182 people faint
with chuck palahniuk reading guts oh
golly matt beer back in action what's up
dude i also thought jim from the office
was a good mr fantastic i hope we see
him again very soon people are gonna
forever know him poor guy yeah man he's
forever jim he's jim halpert shaves the
shaves the beard looks at camera mr
fantastic you know there's a multiverse
out there where reed richards works for
dunder mifflin you know i'm okay with
that
i'm i'm cool it's a really successful
dunder mifflin it is it's the most
evolved paper company
i mean spinoff parks and rec nick
hofferman's my dream mr things and the
thing
imagine the thing it's clobber in time
[Laughter]
actually perfect yeah i think it'd be
the right amount of humor yeah i think
it'd be really fun yeah because i think
you've had the
chance for nick offerman to show his
back because there's something i think
what makes nick alfred appealing is his
he's every man he but he's every man
he's funny but he's also intimidating
he's hyper-messy yeah yeah and his
deadpan allows for a great oscillation
between humor and pathos right because
he is a good actor and you've got a guy
that's trapped as a rock creature you
want to be very empathetic towards him
so his voice needs that he just needs
the mustache too leomar 89 i loved the
movie but the cameos were
okay
yeah i mean they shouldn't they really
shouldn't have shown any it would have
been really special they really
shouldn't have shown any in the in the
in the trailers i mean
the fact that he gave away
freaking captain carter in the in this
insane to me because i didn't hear that
rumor i assumed it because of what if
but i didn't hear it and the fact that
they gave away for the professor x chair
yeah
yeah because the voiceover was a moment
we freaked out about but they didn't
give away the chair i mean even when the
way he showed up in the chair in the
trailer it looked like it was one of
like the days of future past futuristic
suits you know yeah black that's what it
looked like there the chair is funny is
[ __ ] one of those shots oh man it's
so big so big such a mess
i'm like dude you get caught in the
doors when you go to the grocery shop
yeah no that man does not go it looks
like hospice care professor
like is there an iron lung in there too
is there a fridge in there yeah
that's a good idea yeah because in the
animated series professor x is like buff
as [ __ ] like yeah he's like this big
dude where he's not like you know the
rock fight but he's blocked but he's a
big guy
you know
you guys look like fragile and they did
not equate the share sizes
patrick stewart and not that i'm not
that i wanted them to de-age him or
anything but it is weird to see somebody
who's one of those people who's like
this guy's been old always but now he
actually kind of looks old yeah when
he's walking around he looks good though
yeah we saw him with the red carpet no
no no i mean in the movie in the dream
sequence oh yeah we saw him also walk
the red carpet he was out there good for
you guys
wesley phelps agatha had the dark hold
for a while why didn't she go crazy like
wanda or get a third eye like doctor
straight because they hadn't figured out
that they were going to do that yet
she's just doing bad [ __ ] the whole time
yeah
not the nice she was the villain and
she's naturally a villain too yeah and
dark fingers and all that she got
corrupted and who knows maybe agatha was
nice before she had the dark cold we
just only met her with the dark hole
like really and uh to answer your third
eye question that wasn't um because the
dark hold per se it was because the
spell he did by going into a dead body
exacts a higher toll of magic so when
you're doing um you know the certain
spells exact a bigger toll so there's
actually a really cool comic book story
line where doctor strange is revealed to
having an entire basement of sentient
beings that he kind of transmutes his
magical toll on to which equates to
basically like
[ __ ] up slavery and like what that
cost is so i really hope they address
that with clea by having this third eye
thing be like oh there is a consistent
toll what does he do to you know release
that and and i hopefully that's the
third movie is
true that son man i agree with you my
boy my child is such a child of the
father and the son of the holy ghost we
are going to continue reading the super
chats
um but what i wanted to say is
that we have to stop
the super chats
because we i have
plans with my my mom
even though i said you've done nothing
for me my entire life you neglected me i
watched multiverse of madness you would
never do that for me you would never you
would accept that i am no longer part of
this earth
you would stay in your own multiverse
your own universe and never travel
further than that assuming my mom has
power she still wouldn't do it she'd be
like i'm gonna go watch i'm gonna go
watch the lawn order you know i'm gonna
stay here i'm gonna search every
universe for the best law order season
before can you turn off the super jets
before my mom's in the chat somewhere
how mom uh hey
yeah
it's coming on mother's day of all time
corey
uh why would it be weird
[Laughter]
hey you're better in person ladies nice
to meet you koi's hot mom yeah i'm like
yeah i'm mrs koiha mom you're even
hotter in person my good friend greg and
i'm uncomfortable in leaving okay i'll
be over there now that's my fiancee
people sneaking in their super chats
clever folks
now's the time get their last of the
super chats in before what are you doing
did you turn them off
it's fine we're loading doing something
else productive while it reloads no it's
too late all right joey b you you've
you've won this round as the last one we
will take today but you understand the
implications of this action let's focus
on it
you turn off the super chat's like do
you understand the implications it
literally is like until you realize that
your subscribers can not send you what
you've done do you understand the
implica like that was a bigger warning
that we got in all of multiverse and
madness this is the opposite of
capitalism
no you mean you're turning off super
don't want money
thank you guys to all you have
contributed thank you like seriously
it's uh it means the world coincides
with the most of it 78 of people want
want the show that's that's like a c
plus no maybe it's not high enough i
guess not guys
11 of people are here out of spite oh
okay and
only 11 people i put three options does
john give a funny option yes that
confuses the actual tally i was trying
to get yeah
we'll add the two good ones together i'm
counting the joke ones as yeses
basically so i had 89
only eleven percent said no if you want
to be in denial when that's not you know
eighty-five percent we were in a court
of trial
all right
someone just sent a little teepee oh
hooray
uh okay let's get these got this john i
believe in you that's not the one this
is moving along smoothly everyone's lost
their minds yeah zero
two hours it's not bad
220
sanity got it all right michael mack is
back not to hurt greg's feelings but i
was congratulating both the real rejects
channel and john campia
uh he cool congrats to the three of you
also earth 838 left in mordo's hands the
illuminati all dead that world will turn
to poop soon you know my one of my
issues with this dr strange franchises
they were like the next big baddie gonna
be that mordo nope and then like nah
boring
she would tell these universe
fascinating i would have loved it
i'm sure such a great actor and they
just don't know how to perhaps scott
derrickson's script had such things i
he's got she would tell energy for his
third billing too he's the third build
character for like 20 minutes so they
had to hide everyone else he's build
he's built above like sochi gomez and
like
fame but also like with michael
stillberg is in there like he got his
own card
and he had one he's above benedict wong
yeah yeah he is in fact benedict wong i
think his fourth what a bunch of
[ __ ] isn't that weird because yeah i
saw that i was like wong is the other
supporting character besides or supreme
yeah it should be benedict elizabeth
no other benedict
yeah
and then
i mean i would feel it should be uh
zoshi gomez but i get
yeah i get it um but yeah like that's a
weird i i also the with michael
strahlberg made me laugh because i was
like all right that's it i was like
he's got that scene in the church the
only reason he agreed to come back
john britney
just imagine how [ __ ] cool it would
be it would have been if professor x
wasn't in the trailer
i've been imagining it yeah this whole
time that is something i wish wasn't um
revealed yeah it was exciting made for a
great trailer reaction for sure you did
thanks for that thanks marvel they knew
they care about that's for us
i think they followed in sony steps a
little bit in this one yeah matthew
reyes don't say anything about sony koi
you're their boy who's sony morby is
sweet
so you're morpheus sweetheart i'm sorry
he's brought up dad
to use the dark hold after agents of
shield did and not have daisy or robbie
reyes in the illuminati instead of black
bull come on feige coulson lives he does
justice for all my peeps quake
did go on circle of colson was on the
council i would have loved
and the thing is the show would allow
for it based on where they go i'm cool
with coulson existing in another
multiverse i don't think like he
literally is the reason they avenge i
don't i personally i mean team 616
coulson died i i understand you're
griping i'm just sure makes that a main
thing and i love that they did they deal
with it head-on i'm just saying
coulson in the multiverse would have
worked for everyone both sides fair fair
yeah fair enough fair enough all the
agents of shield killer on wong turley
doesn't deserve the title of sorcerer
supreme he dishonored the deaths of
hundreds of wizards by handing over all
the secrets of the darkhold after it was
destroyed
thoughts
hey hey
hey he he kept people alive i did it to
save four people those four people and
one of them was a minotaur are better
now for it hey that was wrench
yeah that was a massive deal that
character also got a credit like a card
yeah yeah it was a major deal and the
movie utilized that
the character did things all the
potential realized
that was like some x-men [ __ ] where they
just haven't actually just said
gambit is in the in the as we zoom
through there's jubilee who has that
cool they're in the movie that's
something like they're not an actual
character they don't i don't know if the
did rintros speak i don't think you had
a line or two okay
i remember them clearly
tech window
that is that is tricky because the
sorcerer supreme is is responsible and
that is a uh you know weighing the
living for the dead like that's a tricky
thing he lost so many people he was so
desperate about it and he was trying to
save yeah commerce in general he already
let like a bunch of other people die not
not a great day not a great let me just
keep these five i need my minotaur
he's got a credit so we need to keep him
alive tech window i needed iron crews
costly but imagine just showing tom
cruise in your trailer as iron man not
needing to show the other cameos well
that would be your ace in the whole
thing that would be
your biggest one don't give away the one
people would almost be in disbelief over
yeah and we still might be who knows
i'm in disbelief i don't know what
i hope that there's a director's cut
that's the same movie but that just has
like the seventh generation amount of
cameos yeah don't you know rob
whitefield yep
talk to him for us yeah rob tom allen
your friends tell your secrets what's
the deal rob i think that deadpool was
we need to scoop school scoops
of scoops phil co officially confirms
that tom cruise and nicole kidman
reunited
um next trial coming soon
dude get the nicole kidman amc chicken
oh there's multiverse actually if they
cut here they are if they cut to the
illuminati and it was her sitting down
in her chair about to watch her move
she just goes heartbreak feels a little
better in a place like this
that's the multiverse of madness i want
that
they played the shorts they played the
short version i was so bummed oh the
cowards they they let her sit down way
too fast left door and lol i did like
the film i just expected more because
the bar for the mcu is so high now it
made me get hyped for the future
especially for fantastic four especially
if krazynski directs it anyway can't
wait for what's to come take care
guys i'm with lev here can you imagine
the the amount of satisfaction that
marvel that marvel fans had seen
krasinski and then feige's like
nah
someone else
we'll do something with that later
here's the reason we killed them off
it was a trial run it didn't work out
just uh i didn't like it everyone kept
calling him
oh thank you guys for your contributions
and
nikoi
no john i haven't done anything today
i'm just getting us back to this is the
first time i've done a live stream
without any food in my system yeah no
same oh i had an apple but it was like
six hours ago not great a six hour apple
yeah
we should i
every day i'm like i'm gonna do
intermittent fasting i'll start at 1 30
and then i'm like ah [ __ ] i'm having my
dinner at midnight
yeah yeah this is not intermittent
i'm not taking care of going to sleep
with a bunch of food in myself
i don't put your calories in at the end
of the day greg it's not the move
all right
you got this john i believe in you
fill in the silence all righty
[Music]
i think we're at
yes name that theme song elmest let's
get these back on the screen
all right elm asked what i heard when i
heard the x-men theme i went crazy it
was so nostalgic hearing that yes it was
really cool and the second time we were
actually able to hear it yep yep because
the first time it was like
i i literally had to overhear somebody
go the x-men theme to understand why it
just happened because people were still
cheering over patrick stewart and it was
the orchestral like the scope of it that
was the song but with more oomph which i
really enjoyed and i like to have my
hand here just if i look at it we're
going to put your head in
that dune box
that fight club neck harness from the
guy at the end and i just live in my
cage
the jay shrey way appreciate this moment
of silence we love you for me to look
forward mark leach hi guys are there any
superheroes that if they appear as part
of the illuminati would have had you
shouting out in excitement to see
um
are there any superheroes that they
appear as part of the illuminati would
have had you shout out in excitement to
see
i mean i got pretty excited when john
krasinski showed up
even though i must admit that was ruined
for me um unfortunately i was on twitter
and was not looking it up and it got
ruined for me
i i started to 36 hours i needed
yeah and uh and that was a bummer but i
still really felt it when he showed up i
was like maybe it's like okay
if he showed up though i was like oh
cool
what's funny is i i saw the leaks after
and then the leaks look worse than some
of the photoshop i saw from like four
years ago so like the leaks look like
the photoshop that my brain was doing or
i was like that's not real and it like
yeah uh what's funny is what never got
ruined for me was who lashana lynch was
playing huh
everyone was saying that it would
probably be um
uh like spectrum mm-hmm
or her being full captain marvel was
photon yeah but then her being just
captain marvel like oh
cool
uh i mean i would have i would have
loved to seen uh the iron man of any
iron man anymore would have been cool
name wouldn't get an actual you know
water first and get a new character like
you know that wasn't well he would have
died immediately
homelander the deep
i was going to say
i mean come on they're right there
batman i love to sing batman
my illuminati is nicholas cage's ghost
rider yeah reeves is ghost rider
nicholas cage's superman ben affleck's
daredevil has been a council of
strangers that's what i mean that's
that's a comic there's a council of
reeds citadel of ricks
[Laughter]
get michael waldron shouts out to tyler
waldron in the chat too a fellow waldron
uh but yeah that would have been good
thanks mark leach
christina's i think neymar would have
been great i think they might have had a
black panther in there but they decided
that like maybe they should oh that's
interesting that could have been the
seventh chair because he's a very big
part of the illuminating comic books
black panther's integral he leads it
sometimes
and as doesn't anymore but
i think we were all expecting like
massive like title character like
captain car like okay a captain america
variant right um an iron man variant a
thor variant wouldn't cool i mean i'm
glad they didn't do jane foster there
because that's going to be such a moment
later
coy christine explain more who clea is
please so
this is one of my favorite things
she has not looked it up because uh
there has literally been i've never
gotten more texts than after doctor
strange two of so many people going who
was that uh i think this is the most
confusing post-credits scene in a long
time clea is played by charlize theron
uh a fellow sorcerer who is the next
love interest of doctor strange so the
closure we got with rachel mcadams here
goes immediately into a as powerful uh
dr strange parallel in clia but she has
a bit more nefariousness to her
sometimes she's working against him
sometimes she tricks him into using her
magic sometimes she tricks him into
using his magic in ways that harm him
sometimes she's on our side but she's
always kind of self-serving it's
whatever clea needs to get done um also
her origins are kind of messy because
it's not always uh human like there are
some some continuities where it's like
you don't know really where she comes
from as far as genetically
yeah like so it's it's sometimes they're
like she's a person and sometimes it's
like an alien and then sometimes it's
like daughter of dormammu but what's
cool is the conflict is imagine if like
captain america fell in love with red
skull's daughter which is a character in
the comic book sin they don't love each
other they hate each other but imagine
the conflict of something that's this
giant entity that is everything you
don't represent but you love that
daughter so it's it's kind of the
inverse of rachel mcadams where
she understands that he has to go do
these things but she loves him as a
doctor and she wants him to be happy
clea is kind of self-serving and loves
the mystical side of him and his power
set and doesn't really know what to do
with the human elements so it could be a
really cool character
i'm gonna say this right now
i don't think it's a good post credit
scene
i don't either i don't think it's a good
postcard i think especially not after
the ending i think it under cuts the
ending scene pretty fast the ominous
cliffhanger dude it ends so cool and
like what's gonna happen and then he's
like i blink now yeah and i was like i
got this [ __ ] and she's just like
it it felt like tacked on she looks like
a power rangers character the costume
and the makeup and the dialogue was like
i don't know it just rang as not where
sam raimi usually can do cheese that i
find charming
that felt like
not charming at all that that just felt
really weak and and i did not like the
way it was executed not i'm not it's not
that clia being introduced is the thing
i don't like it's it's the handling of
that post credit scene that i did not
find a particularly good post it also
felt like the joke of people that don't
like marvel that say like
nerds wait 10 minutes in the credits and
then blah blah blah i'm here jumps
through a portal like they did that yeah
no it felt like when another studio
tries to do a post-credits scene trying
to be marvel
but sucks at it yeah and that was kind
of like
oh come on sony stop it it was amongst
my least favorite post-credits scenes
and then like as i'm not a john like
bruce campbell's hilarious i like him
sam raimi happy they're bros but like to
have the post-credits scene at the very
end
after that post-credits scene it kind of
felt like a one-two punch of like eh if
you're not an evil dead fan you're not
gonna give a [ __ ] about that and that's
hard because yeah and and if it was
maybe like something else going on in
the multiverse that was like story wise
and then you know pizza papa but just
pizza papa and cleo didn't really didn't
land for me well i think like for for
sam raimi with with ash and for sam
raimi with bruce campbell in the
spiderman films
he didn't uh he didn't rely on evil dead
for the the bruce campbell cameos
and then here he just straight up was
like i needed that joke yeah
and and i wish he did kind of like how
he did with um him and spider-man where
he had him be like a fun character well
it was kind of the inverse of the
captain america joke like the in the
captain america joke and homecoming it's
deserved because of how earnest and
honest cap is the sitting down like
you're still here like that joke works
this was the opposite we just met this
character it's not in universe and it's
just like oh i am still here next to the
camera yeah like so i i don't know
didn't work for me personally
it worked really well for me it should
have been 30 minutes longer more set up
illuminati and multiverse hopping i
think
yeah
like that 30 minutes would really would
have let it just breathe a lot better
and you could have
spent more time with the illuminati you
could have done a little bit more you
could spend more time with everybody
yeah
i mean it's like american chavez
even the multiverse hopping part i'm
like you could have gone to another
multiverse sure it might not have been
more it might not have been needed
because you do go to uh some cool places
here yeah because because that part of
where the book of ashanti is is not
the multiverse uh it is a is where the
world what is it the space the space
design
yeah the space between universes yes yes
okay so it's kind of still multiverse
adjacent yeah it's more like a closet
something
that's where they keep stuff they could
probably be accessed from other
universities
what is it the uh what junction is
something in the comics is the nexus of
of thing but they can't use that word
because that also means beings that are
nexus events so like what's tricky is
they've given so much stakes to nexus
beings and then they undermine the
stakes that are nexus peaks
love you koi buzzby boy connor 99. hi
from ireland guys it hurts my ancestors
do you guys think that this incursion
will be the way for the fox universe to
collide with the mcu seems like the
simplest idea to bring a mutants no need
for an origin story
i
conor mcgregor
do you do an irish
i jokes i respect that country so greg
is the best irish accent
yeah now this is the peak this is what
we get right did you say it
[Laughter]
um i think that is a method to do it i
don't know if they're actually going to
keep the x-men canon because what they
showed us here is that you know this
xavier is
a kind of a universal constant but since
we've already met mcevoy since we've
already had different visuals of x-men i
don't think you need to explain the fox
universe i think you could do an
incursion event with those characters
and and have them die off so the
mainstream audience that doesn't
necessarily get comic movies understand
they're no longer your x-men and maybe
also you know if you want to play with
deadpool that way but overall i don't
know if the incursion concept will carry
on past this because it's such a big
concept to half tell and i feel like
this is as close as we'll probably get i
mean the incursion to me seems like it
wouldn't make things very easy at all it
seems like it would wreck a lot of stuff
and and make things uninhabitable for
whoever's involved like that one planet
like that that that strange like evil
planet yeah and also the weird lack of
using what if whatsoever like why wasn't
that strange the evil strange we had and
what if why wasn't any of the continuity
with like like the trailers made it look
like we had zombie wanda evil strange
all those things and the only thing we
really got from what if was agent carter
but that i don't think and it's not even
necessarily this is the same card either
it's a different costume and it's like
different tweets yeah and like she
doesn't like it so it's the concept what
if season one doesn't end with her going
i'm gonna go join the illuminati you
know right like they defeat ultron so
like what if didn't feel like it yeah
set this up like we thought it did
i feel like it just helped you
understand kind of the concept of the
multiverse in a way yeah but i think
loki did that already right yeah yeah um
which also doesn't feel like it is
involved at all the tva wasn't involved
at all you know what i think the
illuminati scene needed everyone needed
an entrance
yes
sit in pen yeah i got an entrance was
[ __ ] like mr fantastic weirdly
showing up late
i was busy
i was doing read stuff
they should have all portaled in in
their own way like the thing with the
shield that kind of like catches it then
it reveals her that's cool yeah then um
but then you would have to have people
doing stuff just to show off for us the
audience yes
yes that's fair uh rayla and rodney
react who do you think will be the big
bad of phase four kang
and kodos i think they're going to
reveal that because it seems like that's
what's what kept the first three phases
of the mcu so focused was you you knew
from avengers 1 this was all building to
thanos like it became it became very
evident and you knew that that was what
was coming so you were always looking
for the direction of that here
everything kind of feels like scattered
and desperate and i like that we haven't
had an avengers announcement in a while
so i think it'd be really badass if like
they don't even announce it at like a
comic-con or something or a d23 that
they just show a trailer at a
post-credits scene yeah like this or
yeah or the young avengers will return
or something something that just
announces avengers secret wars in the
movie itself that'd be awesome i'd love
that please do that secret invasion in
some way
because the first three phases had that
one singular buildup and it makes me
wonder how they're gonna do if they're
gonna do one big bad for this phase and
change it or do some kind of multi-phase
build up of a big big bad yeah i do feel
like this one is intentionally more like
i said at the beginning like desperate
like it's very yeah and so i i don't
know if there's going to be a singular
but we're setting up namor doom and kang
so that's a lot of big bads i appreciate
you guys for the most like more than
most live streams you guys are like
actually asking a lot of different
questions yeah we haven't had a lot of
repeats yeah that's a that's a
refreshing thing also it hasn't been a
lot of like this is a thing what of this
thing like it's been like actual
conversations that's where the rest of
this goes
nobody super chatted a morbius sweep
that's awesome
you see wanda appearing thanks seb ford
appearing in agatha series potentially
being trained by agatha
i feel like they really need to make
agatha her own thing i think she can
make like an appearance sure actually
based off of the events of here if she
like goes into hiding and then they do
they really do the training thing yeah
maybe she goes back and wakes her up and
is like hey i need your help because
doesn't uh agatha train train her yeah
and and the comic books like you know
that you couldn't do that in one
division because the reveal wouldn't
work but now that we know what agatha is
and that it was her all along that would
be a fun way to do that comic story yeah
that'd be actually great and i'd love to
see those visuals because there's so
much great stuff with agatha and one
dagor and like full witchcraft and stuff
and that and wanda needs the training
well
but also like maybe like rebuilding her
like without darkhold or like rebuilding
her magic in her control or like maybe
doing some of those things uh and and
that's what um
elizabeth olson's been saying a lot is
like shirley wants to lead into the
witch side of scarlet witch going
forward cool
zuri berry do you think earth 616
strange will look for reed richards and
the rest of the illuminati
not according to that post-credits i
don't feel like he even valued them yeah
i don't think he cares about much uh
like it just feels like he's off doing
his own stuff which to be fair is very
much comic book doctor strange like
people are always knocking on his door
like any time any mystical magical stuff
happens spider-man's like bruh and like
when and like he's usually not even home
uh so doctor strange is like dealing
with a lot message for you strange i've
needed your help for six years uh but
like doctor strange is usually off doing
his own thing he's tied into the comic
books but he's arguably more of a
defender than an avenger and the
defenders are silver surfer hulk doctor
strange and
the fourth kind of rotates but i i'm not
placing right now sometimes anyway danny
rand the iron man yeah like we're like a
thing like yeah danny rand like there's
not that but anyway uh those characters
are more mystic based and big than the
defenders we got in the netflix universe
which are literally street level so
doctor strange isn't as much of a team
player as we've had him be so far in the
movies yeah yeah
all right
sup guys thoughts on wanda completely
destroying the illuminati personally i
don't think this will be the end for
each of the members no and i think
that's what gets a little people
dismayed when they don't need to be like
dismayed of they thought i think what a
lot of people expected and right
understandably so you like you showed
the you know professor x in there you
think this is going to be the
introduction of mutants it feels like
it's going to kind of be
what the comics sort of but i feel like
this i feel like the real multiverse of
madness is going to be secret wars
because because we got x-forced we think
we met these teams yeah well i think
they we thought that they were going to
like smash multiverses together right in
some way and then then we're gonna have
mutants and like oh this is how they get
brought over into here but no these are
just alternate versions and we will get
the real versions of them yeah like
uh we will get a professor x you know
yeah and i think we're getting them soon
but i don't
i don't know like i feel like i feel
like the first 10 years of marvel were
very curated and set up and then the
next five years of marvel were going to
be setting something up and then kovit
happened and they had to rewrite a lot
and i feel like what kevin feige setting
up now is the next 10 years of marvel be
as tight as the first 10 but i do think
there's going to be a couple more bumps
like i feel like we're going to have to
sort this out to get back into that
pattern bob chapex stepped in and was
like we spent billions of dollars buying
them throw a couple of them in there
just toss santa mcavoy jesus figure out
we put mr fantastic and x in there
ryan's busy making three guys seven we
can't you know how much this costs us
let's build a ride instead how far hey
inhale burrito i would love to i would
love that how far do y'all think disney
will go with the blood and possibly gore
now after seeing this and mooncanite uh
i think they will
go as close as they can they've gone as
far as they can on a pg-13
i think having sam raimi for that effect
is good because he knows how to do that
like drag me to hell is pg-13 and at
times i forget insane like he knows how
to push the like find the right tone and
mpaa is so stupid find the macabre
nature of it to the point where it's
like it's not it's not exactly r-rated
but we got there we skirt the line just
enough
it's it's so arbitrary like you can
literally take out a couple frames like
fast and the furious the first fast and
furious a movie that by no means is
close to rated r was rated r for the
first three cuts because they hold on
the dude when if you haven't seen fast
and furious fix your life uh the scene
where he jumps on the truck and he's got
the thing wrapped around his arm and
he's hanging and it gets bloody they had
to recut that three times because of
blood on a guy's arm due to like a metal
thing wrapped around it that movie isn't
even close rated r but because of blood
the audience is uh
the npa thinks we can't hang but then
this movie is full on terrifying i don't
think this needs to be rated r either
but i don't think the pg pg13r system is
as cut and dry as people assume it is so
this question is inherently loaded
because we've got things like blade
coming out we've got werewolf by night
we've got all these things but some are
on tv which is a completely different
system and blade i would argue needs to
be rated r but i don't know if
this new version is going to reflect the
version we're used to sure i just i
would be surprised because like the old
ones are so good i just rewatched them
all they're so like blade is it holds up
so much better than i would have ever
dreamed wait trinity man
that's how we got deadpool where the
money's at that's where the magic
happens
that ipod commercial jessica oh yeah
someday i'll watch blade ryan gilliam
you've never seen blade oh i've got a
story about blade all three
yeah
can we do a reaction to john watch can
we do a reaction of me watching john
watch blade
that'd be very distracting
in a box within a box
right it's just
like somehow koi's reaction is bigger
than joe
we went to see i'll tell this story when
we when we have time uh ryan gillen what
if doctor strange an american chavez
teleported to hogwarts the american
chavez yeah
i i do love all those times where
they're like we gotta save america
america not the multiverse
that's how we would prioritize it if we
actually had multiversal drive we got to
protect every america
uh what if doctor strange in america
chavez teleported to hogwarts and teamed
up with wizards to stop wanda
okay so you got that should have been
canon that should have happened clearly
malfoy's on the illuminati and he was
just he was the seventh chair yeah
because he had to go talk to his father
um but i do
who would be the hogwarts illuminati
mcgonagall malfoy
hermione for sure
dave comes out in the wheelchair and
does the whole like maybe he's good yeah
let's see what kind of
dumbledore can't speak uh it would be
fun let's get that wb warner bros merger
wb disney merger going dakota jones not
for batman and spider-man but for
hogwarts and witchcraft or for my man
batman spider crossover
jones will kang
control battle world subscribe to coda
jones on uh instagram uh one underscore
virus effects he does cool [ __ ] uh kang
will control battle world what do you
think coy i love this question because
you know what battle world is and that
is something that's going to be very
near and dear and nerdy very soon i do
think we're getting to that level i do
think we're getting to the world of
secret wars and all those big things in
battle world i do think it's gonna be a
way to bring things together like greg
was suggesting i don't know if it'll be
kang because i've always seen kang as
someone kind of above that [ __ ] like he
was a guy that just like i'm doing what
i want for me i'm a conqueror i run all
this stuff i don't have time for
semantics i don't care about these
people battling i don't care about
heroes and villains that's the beyonder
and that's the difference between the
beyonder and kang i do think we're gonna
get the beyonder i love the idea of kang
opening up the um everyday person's
possibility for this big of a character
i think kang is gonna be kang's our
gateway drug like kang is our lead into
what's to come with beyond her and all
those things
yeah you just need a little the first
one's free and loki um but like i do
think that's what's coming and i think
it's gonna get a lot bigger and bigger
and bigger from kang ab fab deadshot no
no the jay shrey way
glad you loved the movie ginger skye
where was vision in good wanda's reality
he was the white guy that you saw him as
in the first episode of wanda vision yep
just casual
straight edge boring guy white paul
bettany office working guy yeah
sharing information on the yakity yak
dead show
dceu character wants to know just got
back from watching the film sony needs
to take note for venom three this is how
you get away with violence also big fan
of uh since the tasm 2 trailer wowie
that's a long time thank you for
following that's when i first started
covering a [ __ ] tennis tv spot that's
cool back in the day
whacking the day the whacking the
that movie baby full-heartedly for
everyone everyone loves it still talking
about it lived up to the hype thank you
buddy i appreciate it yeah i think sony
sony needs to take more notes
than just that
you know
just a couple right koi i like movies
i like movies very much i like different
movies for different reasons different
ways talk about it here we are talking
about movies we love like the movies
is that cool
what do you think sony could apply from
the mcu to make the morpheus franchise
really reach its full potential i think
it should have a post-credits scene with
clia in it uh that's what they should do
yeah ryan sweater hi guys watching you
guys since wanda vision we really
brought in an audience since one
division
marvel launched
the movie
easily one of my favorite i'm really
glad you feel that way especially after
um you know
yeah that's something some of the
discourse comes in the fact from wanda
vision and doctor strange so the fact
that you loved it and thanks for being
here with us for so long the one
division journey is
a journey on that like honestly when
that was coming to a close
i remember feeling really sad about like
not experiencing like even to this day
we haven't covered a show where we were
just so
invested the one division era was a
really special time of like it was it
was event tv yeah true truly event tv
that's how i got my i grew my instagram
a lot through doing like lives and it
was the most engaged i've felt with the
fandom since like avengers i would talk
about it with
people outside of here like all that it
was like such a common conversation i
was having yeah with everyone not just
not reviewing it but just like talking
about what's gonna happen you know like
what's gonna happen and and uh just the
yeah the amount of discussion around it
was just so monumental and then to say
and then like all the videos you were
doing on it beyond just reacting to the
show and then and then i remember like
the night of i was really sad like oh
this is that because it's like saying
goodbye to a friend yeah yeah like
and the show like the shared experience
of the show and the discourse and then
the emotional resonance of the show
itself like yeah i think looking back
i might consider loki a better show
however i think wanda vision
did something stronger than than loki
for me which was i cared way more about
the characters the main characters than
i did in loki it's why i when i did my
ranking i wanna vision is my second but
like
it's it's only
marginal and those two are so different
from the rest there's so many little
things you can tick back and forth
because because one division two breaks
the mold the most yeah in terms of just
style and format and i think about loki
i don't really think about the character
journeys yeah i'm more about it i do i
actually think about myself i actually
do think about the existential
quantities but not as much as one
division but yeah but i love the
characters in loki but like the what got
one division changed for me was like i
liked wanda and vision but i'm like oh
my god i'm in love with him yeah
and you already liked loki a lot whereas
like we didn't get a lot of time with
wanderer vision before then yeah so we
got the most growth because of that yeah
they did in a very
unique way that could only work for
their characters well that's the thing
with this movie too is that with loki i
feel like a lot of what they did with
his character journey you could like you
don't want it to be the same but i'm
like i could see easily how the writer
who guided this series yeah confronted
this character could do that together
this movie but anyway dakota jones back
felt like thank you dakota we love you
felt like
creep show but with a rainy budget
it would be fun for there to be some
type of anthology film that marvel does
one day give it i don't think they ever
will but
i think that would be a really cool like
an actual anthology movie
and there's plenty of stories to only
live there like there's plenty of
stories that can't live in canon it'd be
really fun to have that unique little
pocket i wonder how they could pitch
that maybe they should do that for like
disney plus they should i feel like it'd
be a good theater experience i would
love that they should find a way to do
like
marvel unconnected like here's the main
continuity and then here's something
like some mythology that might factor in
tangentially but is mainly just about
this one it's dc string experience i
really i know dc's crushed it by doing
that yeah i really want them to for
their animated [ __ ] to do direct graphic
novel adaptations the way
the way dc does i'm like why not do that
[ __ ] do your hospital i'd love to see
some stuff we won't do your infinity
gauntlet you know like bring me man
spider
bring him man spider
dude again i want recommendations for
man spider and man bat all right i will
give you all the hybrids you want i got
you give me your faves andrew's first
appearance of morbius speaking of
morbius sweet little man spider action
amazing spider-man 103 after he appears
in one-on-one just like obvious to bring
it or be a sweet you're gonna wish
you're in the audience of course when
he's asking a comment question
who knows this deep cut answer no one
i'm keeping the poster to myself i'mma
keep all these signatures and the
posters you're gonna sit there awkwardly
wondering who this guy is i still have a
morbius poster in the trunk of my car oh
andrew saba have like nine i do and i'm
still trying to figure out what to do
with it so if you want to give them all
to me uh andrew saba happy to see a new
ravy movie after so long loved the way
this movie was so unapologetically
cheesy
strange versus strange music fight was
so awesome and creative by the way last
name is pronounced saba andrew saba i
screwed it up i'm sorry what did you say
saba dumbass
idiot like sega go die now
[Music]
andrew
got a sega t-shirt for when we
eventually react to sonic oh
love that franchise love it so much have
you guys not seen sonic yet waiting for
it to come out first it's in the first
one there was something we had to cancel
our tickets that day and then next
theater showings that are not good seats
so i was like you know what why don't we
just react to this when it comes out
have you seen the first one yeah okay
it's better which is impressive i
actually i'm re-watching it i like the
first one a lot yeah the first one's my
was my favorite video game movie now two
is it's that good koi sega talk is
absolutely absolutely loved the cheese
and the rainy-isms and the creativity
all throughout yeah absolute vodka
garcia it's actually pronounced jar
garcia jar head and garcia doctor
strange and the mcguffins of madness
how many mcguffins
they're collecting they're very
enjoyable mcguffins big you know cisco
the one good thing is that that was that
worlds illuminati and we still have yet
to see the illaminu and lament the
illuminated ramen naked llamas the
illuminati of earth 616.
sure
i think we should
i don't think there is an illuminati on
our earth yet
i think the illuminati i think the
avengers equivalent on that universe the
illuminati and i think they formed
because one of their own not betrayed
them but became corrupt i think the way
we get to the illuminati in the 616
universe is reforming a different
avengers and then them needing some sort
of accountability beyond the avengers i
think the best thing about the
illuminati especially in the comic books
is they're doing so in x-men you've got
your mainstream team and then you've got
like x factor and all these different
teams that have different purposes
x-force is the team that does the things
that no one else can do they're the
mercenaries they're your wolverine your
deadpool your psylocke you're you're
you're bigger powerhouses illuminati
always felt like the intellectualized
version of that to me they always felt
like the thinkers that had to think the
thoughts that no one else was willing to
think but until you get an avengers
reformed in the mcu as we have it it
doesn't really work to have an
illuminati but i agree with what you're
saying i just hope they play the long
game
it's my favorite thought i've had today
you know it's gonna be really exciting
when we see like
shanghai
in the team and eternals yeah you know
turtles was almost in moon night
really yeah they were moon night they
almost they almost had kamel nagani in
the ancient egypt with conscience i
would have loved that yeah i would have
killed that actually would have been
great
would have been perfect right like that
like tone but yeah and funny enough
pokemon and comic book stuff all day
thinks dr strange will turn into the
doctor strange we get at the end of
incursions in the illuminati and doom
world uh
possibility pretty cool pretty cool uh
and uh
adristia
i think kathon thank you adresse i think
a thon is going to be upset with wanna
for destroying his book collection
oh honey have you have you seen my uh
dark holes anywhere i thought i left it
in the crapper have you seen my children
i i do think those uh dark hole uh those
cathon goons whatever the [ __ ] they're
called uh were totally wasted uh jokes
yeah they didn't do anything of a bow
and then they got thrown yeah they
literally did nothing they formed uh
they were great for the trailers uh
jokes aside i hope marvel gets more into
elder god lower yes absolutely
i think i think we're gonna see tons of
weird gods in two months and then i
think that you know we're playing you
have to escalate so gods are a natural
progression so i think they're gonna go
there but we gotta see how it all
ties together thank the weird guys god
like
like uh it ties together in a way that
feels smooth and not disjointed i like
your ambition i like your optimism
i think it's gonna be real weird when we
got zeus and elder gods especially when
it's russell crowe there's gotta be a
way to do it it's gotta be and if anyone
can it's kevin feige i just don't know
for i i don't know if in the next three
movies it's gonna feel cohesive or if
it's gonna take another five movies to
retroactively put it back together it's
not feeling tied together right now it's
not it's not it's not feeling as clearly
tied together that's what i mean i think
you're gonna need a secret wars or a
battle world or um and but feige came
out and said which i guess is part of
the extended canon of
the multiverse of madness that uh the
events of kang the events of kang and
loki are the reasons all this stuff in
spider-man and loki are happening but
they need a movie to say that yeah they
need that
by and that's why i think at the end
it's going to wrap up because i trust
kevin
true power is in the dark hole
[Music]
yeah that's uh that's phillip that
sounds like
but like you know what i mean like you
need the movie that is going to go
retroactively like how age of ultron is
a better movie now than it was when it
came out i think we're going to get a
lot of movies that culminate in
retroactively patching these holes in
the tires yeah it's gonna be great i
love can't wait i love retroactively
catching holes and tightening that's uh
yeah man thor the dark world's the best
now
all righty uh hey honey
genghis khan is saying what's up sister
i know krazynski was a fan cast for a
long connie but as someone who knows
connie i'm going to invite you over
summer you know very little about
fantastic four reed and krazynski
outside of the office what makes him the
top choice among so many fans miss you
dudes miss you too i hope you enjoyed
the nicholas cage movie i assume you've
seen it by now so good i think he just
ha there's this natural
he could i think he's proven himself
where he could be an action hero and
there's also this he's proven himself
that he could lead as well he said
something with john krazinski that he
had to prove that's the number one thing
he had to prove coming out of the office
too
was can he be a lead
because he was he was the main he was a
highlight one of the biggest stars in
the show but at the end of the day he
was a supporting character
and it's a much bigger difference you
become the lead character he can lead he
he has the
there's something that feels like it's a
natural sincerity to the way he could be
reed richards because that's a big part
of him where he also has proven that
he's not just sarcastic jim halpert he
could actually be a really sincere guy
there's a lot of qualities about john
krasinski the person that
fit
beyond just the aesthetic yeah but yeah
the aesthetic's important obviously
because it's comic books and we like the
the drawings to look like our characters
but i think the biggest thing for me is
that he not only feels like a leader but
he also feels like he could be a family
man marvel's first family family
well like the the marvel's first family
is marvel's first family like it's it's
the x-men are a family that are because
they've been put into a situation and
the avengers are a family because they
work together but marvel's first family
is a family where you've got reed who
feels impossible guilt about what i
interrupt you someone in the chat oh
where was it said koi is so hot i had to
say it way to lose that john oh i'll
find him oh oh oh deny a dancer should i
place the pin comments
uh yes that's very important sorry sorry
new rock stars
you're getting out of here my dark holes
what they're focused on koi's dark hole
is the hottest
hotness
everyone look on the floor turquoise
does anyone see it let me put it
the family aspect is what means so much
to me is that you've got the thing who
is his best friend that is forever
a monster that's traumatized and you've
got the guilt of reid richards who's the
most intelligent man in the multiverse
not being able to solve the problem he
caused you've got you know johnny who is
the human torch who's this reckless
hothead that loves his sister that reed
has to deal with that he loves but he
doesn't understand you've got sue and
reed who are both very intelligent very
incapable not being able to handle all
the pressure of being scientists and
adventurers but also heroes and you've
got all of that while also being a guy
that isn't always likable so you need
him to be very likable that way when
he's not likable you're like oh i get
this character in a different way than
your doctor stranger tony starks who are
very unlikable in other ways so i think
that reed richards casting is one of the
hardest ones to get right because the
character there's a reason the other two
movies didn't work as well because the
family aspect is first the action
adventure is second but those cannot be
shortchanged at the cost of the family
so
john krasinski is perfect because he
embodies all of those things and we have
certain associations with him and
because he cares and his caring shows
and all of his work and i think it's
gonna be really essential i'm excited
yeah you know i agree especially on the
care part because even in that moment
when he's connecting with wanda that was
my favorite part of his whole thing was
when he's trying to talk to like get
through to wanda yeah like stop this you
you have that character that krazynski
that expression in the eyes that he does
that's why you can do a performance like
a quiet place and have limited dialogue
but still be a gripping actor the good
big [ __ ] eyes are
yeah his new show like i that was it
helped me get through the pandemic man
some good news was was one of the only
things that like kept me sane man yeah
because he's like a good and i think his
relationship with emily blunt makes it
that much more appealing because then
you're like i buy him as a family man
because they always
get an invisible underwear gag
in the eventual somehow i doubt this is
uh this is the movie part they also seem
like he he seems like their relationship
at least appears like they seem like
they really get along yeah and they have
a lot of fun together yeah yeah like
they have a great sense of humor with
each other so that is one of those
things of i would i it would be cool for
emily blunt also i mean i'd love that if
she wants to but only if she wants to
because she said she'll give a [ __ ] make
the bad flag movie okay make the mad
flag
wrap him to a chair film his face mocap
the rest
do it like
just just stalk him around and then get
him cut together yeah just have him beat
up the paparazzi that are stalking him
make it a bat suit batman hates cameras
hates him so much jacob belts am i the
only one who thinks wiccan and speed
aren't coming to the mcu she can't take
variant kids to the 616 universe it'll
cause an incursion uh yeah i think they
need to do something about those kids
they messed up they are not
they are
they are not
i even in one division i felt like they
they they needed more writing
for me to really care about well at the
end of the one division arc the voices
crying out made it feel like they could
come back to the 616. and then this
whole movie was like they can't that's
the whole plot well it's funny because
in the one division one they're like
oh that's what they meant by the scream
earlier in the chat that bothered me so
much because that's a young avengers
moment and like the fact that they
didn't make that important i'm like you
guys are setting up young avengers and
you ignored how you're setting up young
avengers yeah you know they're they're
not that appealing of like they're they
they don't know how to write kids
a lot of time and i think they're the
kids are they're just like what do like
hollywood character kids behave and so
i'm gonna sing about ice cream yeah they
feel very ambling kids but the rest did
not she's gonna sit and watch tv all day
is what those kids do and eat ice cream
and debate basically if you pay
attention to when they burst through the
wall america and wanda
you see oh god i mean the name is mixed
up which one is the green one
the long-haired one long-haired one is
that one speed
speed okay
oh i don't know the kidney
i was like
i think tommy is speed right that one
when they're through the wall even the
speed is just looking at the tv when
they're
worst avenger ever
has no hero instincts all right tommy
speed right
the worst avenger adam from the fanpop
thanks man hey guys it was awesome
meeting john and coy on the carpet last
week oh snapchat i'm so glad because
greg's my least favorite how you doing
you guys were so cool and took a pic
with me and my wife thank god greg
wasn't there he would have ruined it
what are your guys thoughts on where we
go with the real rejects now that we can
get greg out of here
what do you think is next for greg after
he leaves here
insane writing success what do you guys
think god uh what do you think is next
from wanda
i mean well once greg writes the next
american i'll write it yeah
i i liked the uh it's cool you guys got
to meet him um yeah tag us in that
picture post that picture and tag us
yeah and invite them to the bedroom with
your wife yeah let's all have a a a
group activity can we bring in fan pops
as long as we can bring in
like we'll do it pups
a bed of fun where do we go from here
you go into the thor love and thunder
that's guns and roses song man kinky
where do we go now
i think uh i i i don't know where
they're going with this franchise right
now that post-credits scene really
rubbed me the wrong way uh so i think
wanda like i mentioned earlier i would
love to see
as they explore their relationship with
magneto i think that'd be a really
interesting thing i don't know if
they'll do it they've made her
continuity so muddied they really could
bring in magnet and be like yeah we were
wrong about that miracle kid stuff um
but like they can make that work because
they've gotten rid of her accent they've
gotten rid of a lot uh that said
i think they need to let
the wanda arc breathe for a minute and
bring her back with kind of the
retroactive
bike tire patching like you need to get
that seven and eight arc between six and
nine that this movie that i keep
referencing you need to make sure you
understand her motivations without the
dark hold as a macguffin you need to
understand those things so i would focus
on maybe a wanda movie i want like her
to get some time and maybe pop up in
agatha to remind us how much we love her
but i think she needs her own time to
grow as a character and i wouldn't even
mind if that's how you introduce uh you
know some of the trauma of magneto
and it was nice to meet you
it very much was
edwin raj thank you so much for jumping
in doctor strange that's a good thought
i can't remember it doesn't matter jump
in when it comes doctor strange movie
without a mirror universe strange
fighting wanda in mirror universe would
have been interesting to see i mean he
technically traps her there for a hot
second doesn't i love the way that
sequence was realized so pretty that was
really the lack of music too
and then one moment like strange might
have something on her and the way she
figures it out yeah oh so great and
great blend of practical and and cg
because like those glass shards uh that
appears i like how it is they try to
trap her and she figures her way out a
lot of the time what i what i'm finding
in this conversation we've had for a few
hours is that i really really really
enjoyed the sequences as much as i felt
like i did but just as you said as soon
as i left it didn't leave me with with
more and so like i do think the movie
was exceptional in many many many many
sequences i just don't feel like i
walked out of having experienced the
34th installment in the mcu nor do i
feel like i've experienced a
continuation of either doctor strange
rwanda and those are essential things
you know what i think that post credit
scene should have been
anything i think it should have just
been clear learning about strangers
going out and deciding to go find him
yeah instead of seeing him like
yeah yeah
and to rejoin him just again strolling
down the sidewalk yeah dude dude is
hanging out on blinker street just
chilling homeboys in soho you can find
them right now
that was moments later after that yeah
sorry
that was weird he conjured himself up a
sweater and he's fine yeah i mean what's
dr strange three gonna be like you just
hop into whatever they're doing uh so
that's what i mean it's like what do you
want to see if that's what this did they
meet him anyway
jacob aison
john bean should play the next professor
x and plot twist he doesn't die
i wonder if he would does that have the
right head
i think his head's too handsome we gotta
shave his head and find out yeah well
smack always got a handsome head and
he's handsome yeah i don't know why
i feel like you need to go a little
younger um to to start a franchise i
love sean bean but i don't know if you
can start with sean
uh i um
i want sterling k brown richard jenkins
i think yeah i think certainly brown be
an exceptional fester x because he's
really intellectual he can lead he can
also play both soft well spoken but also
very aggressive you could go into the
darker side professor expert he also is
someone that i could see like making
uh children afraid of him and respect
him but also like have them want to
inspire greatness so certainly he browns
my uh i press tracks yeah there's a good
warmth he can bring out yeah and while
like and you need to be
he's almost like
the scariest headmaster of all time
while also being someone that inspires
greatness at all time and that that's
really important i think sterling's got
that i think alex jones is better
i
yeah ben shapiro yes that's who we need
i think these mutants need to be locked
up
they're great brotherhood of evil
mutants characters
simmons professor x yeah
there's plenty of senators and
characters in the x-men universe they
can play all right spidey no you're my
best friend vince shapiro as jennifer
kelly
spidey oh eight seven zero he sent us a
moment of silence moment of silence
thank you my friend you andrew davison
uh after watching this movie i liked it
but didn't love it that's i'm sorry the
more i thought about it the more i agree
with my friends and was unsure how i
felt about it i am writing a letter to
send to marvel studios to let them know
how i feel and openly the letter is for
me and me alone so mailing it to myself
mail it to myself as a waiter then i
will bury it in the backyard i realize i
have fun with it but i have more
criticisms than before that's the kind
of movie it is
i didn't really have i didn't i couldn't
quite pinpoint my gripe with the as much
as i found it exciting with the cameos i
couldn't quite pinpoint until my second
viewing and i was like i get it now yeah
they're very similar that post credit
scene though does bother me
yeah opening bothers me
bothers
[Music]
i love the gargantos fight yeah i love
it it feels like
it feels if i keep saying this it feels
like sam raimi's spider-man but like
this is going on the other side of new
york with doctor schrain yeah one it is
one of the few moments where like as he
is jumping into that fight you see a
couple like just regular citizen
perspectives he saves a couple regular
there's a guy who tries ramming his
motorcycle in a gargantus and i don't
know why
he was just wasn't paying attention he
was just trying to help him in a glory
yeah guys that was clearly ghostwriter
before he got his powers did you guys
not catch that
and i hear their supernatural [ __ ] so
i'm gonna go talk to the pistol
mephisto confirmed
frankie j how much did
the pandemic mess with the mcu and this
movie i feel like we did we don't have a
linear way we're going with these movies
but i might be all right with that i
think it messed with the mcu sorry john
what are you going to say no go
on red oh no
multiverse um yeah i would say that
this movie was supposed to come up
before spider-man so there are some
scenes that
seem re-shot you know yeah and a certain
character is supposed to bring someone
through portals
also her in the opening of the movie
that bothers me so much wouldn't have
bothered me if we'd met her in no way
home wait was this supposed to come up
before spider-man yeah
no no no no no no no way home was first
and then this it was always that way
yeah for some reason wait am i wrong i
could be wrong i could be absolutely
wrong was spider-man supposed to or or
am i getting a mix up with the sony
verse yeah i'm not i don't remember the
original order now and i was so sure and
i think i think i think it was morbius
was coming before no way home oh yeah
yes yes
okay so no no this was supposed to come
out after no way but but she was
supposed to be in no way home that's she
was supposed to be introduced which
would have been more more applicable to
the opening where we care about her
because if she brought in toby and
andrew you're automatically going to
care about this character i mean that
way when she's running from something
you're like no not her
well there are reports that this was
really originally supposed to take place
at least before no way home maybe that
wasn't necessarily supposed to be i
don't know if it was supposed to be
released then but it's supposed to
originally take place before that okay
yeah my memories i don't think it really
[ __ ] with it that much i feel like i
think i i don't know why they shorten it
up so much
i mean i i buy what you kind of
expressed which is the idea of like they
had maybe a five or ten year plan going
then the pandemic happened then they're
like whoa
we gotta kind of adjust for uncertainty
another restructuring and now we're
getting a better long-term structure
like that's kind of how i feel so i feel
like it definitely played some impact
but not as much as it could have i think
there's a reason we don't have an end of
phase four in the announcements and i
think they're letting that flow yeah
thank you louie berry for the
superstition oh look at that so cute
thank you
miss stuff four to seven mom is the
perfect movie to take your moms to see
yeah be like be more like her yeah mom
fight for me fight for me show me you
love me and don't neglect me by by
hurting yourself i agree thank you for
the super chat last month we had a tax
movie now we got a mom movie
everything's going great man my mom
loves evil dead all these women
traversing the multiverse rate strange
christine chemistry and chavez's acting
both five out of ten for me oh geez wow
i mean i'm not like madly in love with
the strange christine chemistry but i
thought that one scene was much more
solid i liked it a lot here i think uh
the chavez and strange chemistry is not
like monumental i think it should have
had like more of that clear
like possible father mentor or she did
until the very last beat
yeah it didn't um but i think as an
isolated performer she's really good
yeah i don't think any of the chemistry
there's no one here
nothing i haven't talked once about the
chemistry of anyone for a reason yeah no
character except wong and and well
benedict you really love the chemistry
though the in the first scene when
benedict is talking with wanda
yeah yes that's good uh uh not i wanna
confuse you strange is talking to one
yeah i think there's chemistry there is
really strong and i i think the wong and
strange chemistry is strong but true
they don't get a lot of that that's a
carryover though right yeah so but i'm
saying like those only ones were really
cool have we seen strange and wanda
interact before
because they act like they know each
other
oh i think it's a tangential maybe newer
from when he would like brought her in
from yeah and all that but uh yeah
we needed more moments in infinity war
to establish their relationship but i
like the i like that scene i like that
scene a lot um the when they first meet
what i liked american chavez is i i like
social gomez's performance in general i
think it is slighted a bit by just how
brief a lot of her moments are so things
that could probably read better in a
breathable scene maybe don't so much but
i didn't think she was
bad all right she was way higher than 5
out of 10 for me unfortunately for you
a man of culture
so what movie or show do you think
wonder returns in the next doctor
strange movie or the eventual x-men film
something different
young avengers
a one-shot
uh
i think possibly agatha and then
and then i would like x-men is my answer
i mean they have to reserve her for a
property that involves multiverse
considering her main power is multiverse
traveling
rwanda
wanda all right it was america yeah you
did completely like that's not true
that's why i would say young avengers
such conviction
i'm feeling it i'm feeling i'm gonna
have a lunch with my family in
30 minutes hopefully
daniel west did you guys prefer no uh no
way home or multiverse of madness no way
a lot yeah no way home for sure i prefer
the emotional resonance of no way home
i preferred the madcap strange horror of
doctor strange
you didn't perf like the madcap strange
horror in no way yeah it's a weird thing
there are things about this movie that i
would cling to sooner and want to
re-watch with more enthusiasm however
spider-man no way home for the emotional
thing that it is i i think is really
wonderful and compelling so i mean
politics over here
literally no way home goes all the
plotting circumstances ah you know we're
just kind of gonna play fast and loose
with that but the emotion is what we are
focused on whereas doctor strange is
like you know we'll get the emotions
across but we really want to kind of
focus in on this multiverse journey and
so you know i feel like they do
represent kind of opposite approaches in
certain ways i think that last half of
no way home once once they uh heal doc
ock
is just like a almost a perfect movie
for me it's the only thing is dethroned
winter soldier like i think it's my
favorite marvel film
fascinating
winter soldier with mine for five years
and yeah we lost still on the game for
me we're dead yeah
we're dead i didn't think winter soldier
would ever be dethroned but here we are
mills woj
i love the ending and last shot of the
movie and i was so excited and then that
first post-credit scene completely
ruined it obviously the incursion and
secret war stuff is really interesting
do you guys think kang is a villain i do
think kang is the villain uh i wanted to
spin this question uh a tad bit
different boom is it dr strange who
caused the incursion though it doesn't
seem like
it seems like loki did like loki and
loki like loki and lady loki but it's
like just because strange went to
another universe they're saying he
caused an incursion yeah i think it's
because he dream walked into a corpse
well no that's what caused the the issue
the incursion was already happening
so the evil because he dreams because
sinister strange that
dreamwalking was involved right but that
wasn't that but
i'm saying 616 incursion is loki okay
i'm saying evil stranger why didn't cleo
go after sinister strange
or well because that so so
this is asking about um and is the
incursion definitely in the 616. i don't
think incursions happen in 616 is what
i'm trying to say copy like i don't
think we've had an incursion i think
what's happening in 616 is a multiversal
issue
but concursion events and time events
are different things i think in the 616
universe we've had a tva issue where
time and time uh disparities have
occurred but we don't have any planet
collisions in the 616 universe because
it would look like evil strange's
universe we did yeah so why didn't she
go to sinister strange because we don't
know cleo wants
but she was like you caused an incursion
i hate you i think that's supposed to
tease us that there is another strange
moment that happened but it didn't set
it up well i think it was supposed to be
like you've done some [ __ ] and even know
about why was he like cool
third i'm right here
yeah i'm not the same character anymore
yeah i don't know that i can't i
remember five minutes ago when i was in
massive pain and it was an interesting
choice yeah i did not shoot the scene
with charlie's thera
remember the horror movie ending charlie
starring doesn't know what she's talking
about you know what i'm here if he acted
like he didn't have the third eye and
they added in post you didn't even know
wait that undermines the whole thing
oh goodness gracious uh hey vinyl glaze
did wanda teleport away or save herself
as she brought the scarlet witch tomb
down there was a brief red flash as it
collapsed i'd hate for them to kill her
right as she became the scarlet witch i
think it was supposed to hint at that
that brief red flash but then i was also
wondering if that was the additional
part where she destroyed all the dark
holes
i think it was saving her i think she's
alive yeah i i think it i think i think
they tried miscellaneous or the whole
like destroying the other dark holes but
i think she's alive yeah i think she she
it's just his life it's just that we're
not gonna see her for a second thing uh
sebastian omdahl
what do you guys think about young
avengers future now do you think wiccan
and speed is still going to be members
of the team talk about that a minute ago
yeah i think they will be i feel like
they have to try at least in some way
and like figure out how was the question
because like
what will that look like with 616 if
they got rid of that screaming yeah it's
it's a little bit of a mess right now
it's a mess logan blaze
thank you logan for the moment thank you
for the moment of silence christopher
wolf
thank you chris enjoy the film would you
have liked to seen white vision and
multiverse of madness i missed his
presence here thanks fellas what if the
reveal was the whole thing were like
vision had his concerns about the
multiverse and then they go to the other
wanda and then the post-credits scene he
white vision walks through the door
yes the husband of that
put like
yes honey i'm home from the multiverse
where no dangerous things took place all
as well i love the multiverse i do feel
like you know we were definitely lacking
in vision
uh uh but i do listen to so many layers
i understand the reference
but i also guys i tell you uh but i also
feel like it will be one of those things
where it might work long term um another
interactive patching of the tire i do
feel like they might explain where he's
been and i do feel like we're getting
more vision just this one lacked vision
i mean i'm surprised we got like no
vision at all and water didn't even seem
concerned about getting a vision she's
like i only want my kids it's so weird
however
don't want vision i shot him to the head
and felt nothing
um oh she does mention him there jordan
garza how did y'all feel about the
krazynski cgi i'm assuming you're
talking about the stretch effects um i
think they
i think they're waiting to see how we
all feel about miss marvel first
these are fantastic stretch effects that
is so easy to do poorly like yeah it's
gonna look real bad real fast stretch
effects are so hard to get down right
it's it's like i think it's one of the
hardest super powers to capture that
looks good because like space jam bro
well like we have we have so many
textures and stuff and like the suit's
gonna have to look right and like it's
just so easy to get wrong because
everything looks like gumby it just
looks goofy yeah so quickly because it's
like when they're a human they're bones
right and then
also it's the closest thing to looking
actually i just realized this it's the
closest thing to looking like bad cgi
yeah exactly when something's weightless
and when something looks inhuman it
looks like stretchy
it looks really it's really hard to get
stretch effects down so doing it on
purpose is weird yeah like everything
looks bad people often describe bad
human animations i think
if you lean into the creepy part of it
then they tried that
fantastic harder fan four stick didn't
work out for us um
great
i hope john krasinski playing mr
fantastic hopefully solidifies the role
of being six month six mcu what do you
guys think he is the number one topic of
conversation in here i think it's still
up in the air unfortunately we will have
to just wait and see but we are hopeful
that this is the case i like your name i
assume it's a game being a reference
whether childish or crime family jspel v
boom overall love this as a sam raimi
film more than an mcu film only real
gripe is how quickly professor x died
yeah i wish it was more of a mental
battle between the two before they she
eventually wins she does sort of just
like sneak up on him
yeah
yeah i thought it would be a little bit
more like a mind [ __ ] game yeah even
five more minutes of other places in her
mind like just that's one of the things
about this movie feelings are rushed you
want to believe he has a shot yeah and
like professor x kind of a thinker
that's true that's a really that's a
really good way to put the problem with
that fight yeah yep noah payton but his
neck only got snapped in the in the mind
of her so did his actual neck get
snapped his eyes were pretty glazed over
we don't know that i don't know you
never know he just was playing dead he
was like well it didn't work in the
minds i'm a possum yeah hey he died in
the [ __ ] x-men three and then they
brought him back with no real life
yeah
they could do it again he's just in the
hospital
he respawned at the hospital noah payton
it's so darker like after i saw it and i
was like how many people died because
this movie dark and different [ __ ]
different movies and to be honest i kind
of hated wanda after she killed charles
xavier and the rest of the illuminati
that's a good feeling it's a good
feeling to have i was more like she's so
badass um
also because i'm not that invested in
these portrayals of the illuminati these
characters are not as sad as i should be
i should feel a lot more about professor
x getting murked so quickly but that's
only because of my association with
another professor
[Laughter]
how many years of history have brought
me to this moment but i just met all
these other characters
um
but yeah i i but i understand you're
supposed to feel that conflict i think
yeah i understand i understand i
understand don't worry noah i i i i
don't slice your feelings here i am doom
how about when she broke the fourth wall
great touch yeah she's such an ear it's
so cheeky and eerie
and uh like it just solidifies more that
she's in control for some reason and
you're like you see her look at you like
the phone yeah it's scary it is a scary
moment that's usually like a horror
movie ending shot and to do it in the
middle of a sequence
yeah i really enjoyed that and she's
like it's over now uh what i love that
she gets the first wall break uh pre-mcu
deadpool true you know she's aware of
multiverses including her own yeah it's
great so is pizza papa also
i just want to give credit to one
sequence i really loved i loved the um
dreamwalking sequence where there's that
awesome like 90s enya music and she's
just like vibing dude rodriguez
like that sequence is someone asked
earlier your favorite sequence that's
one of them it's a rob rodriguez visuals
that's one of the most cinematic mcu
that's like that's a true montage of
like
symmetry and imagery and thematic you
know loved it yeah that whole sequence
was my dream yeah thematic esoterica
krishna uh morth morthy agree with koi
it's a bee for me mordo and illuminati
is underrated and underused sorry in
this movie i don't think it delivered
the madness much
of horror not so story i think i got
pretty mad at times i thought it got
pretty mad i mean the madness was there
but like it didn't feel
it didn't feel as much of like a chaotic
[ __ ] maybe maybe yeah maybe mad
cappness is yeah it's the multiverse of
mad captain yeah instead of like the
insanity madness it's more just like wow
we're moving really fast
one montage was mad starts off with
defender the madness there they fight
garganto sarah carmartage
the illuminati like i think it's a
pretty
i guess it didn't feel
i don't know i guess well it didn't feel
good
i understand it but i don't really i
don't fully i think it delivers on the
map i personally feel like it does
andrew kelly
um i really love this film although i
would love to have seen the watcher
release supreme strange to fight wanda
in the final battle i really thought
you'd get a watcher it was so weird that
it under i didn't use any of that i
wonder if if feige wants to tie them in
more and they're not allowing it maybe
secret words maybe they're holding that
stuff
i guess we got charlie cox
uh yeah i agree man you seth naomi i
would have liked to see a mid credit
scene of variants of the illuminati wake
up from a dream of juana killing them
leading oh
nice
that would have been a great post
credits can you imagine that dreams
and they all wake up in the same room
yeah
sleep together
but i love that
what are your thoughts on a film where
the villain is driven by her material
instincts
maternal sorry instincts being released
on mother's day weekend i think it would
have been more accurate if it was
material instinct material girl as you
know in a material world me judging
wanda is just shopping across the
multi-man beverly hills husband's credit
card
his viz has been pursuing me across
every universe
i can't call the bank in other universes
call her the scarlet witch she loves
target
the target witch just all red clothes
and khakis i mean the movie trailers
don't really lean into that quality
honestly the trailers don't lean well
they don't always show that she's the
villain
i really enjoy the maternal aspect it's
weird the trailers revealed all the
rogues they really really could have
because the trailers didn't reveal so
much like so much of this movie's not
revealed but the things they did decide
to lean in on totally set the wrong
expectations well yeah they they
advertised a different movie like they
advertised a multiversal cameo laden
hopping journey instead of an awesome
scarlet witch
chase movie yeah she's the terminator
right it feels like they gave no way
home's marketing do to try
yeah
louie fleet
um thank you louie the movie was a sam
raimi special what marvel character if
marvel allows it should he tackle next
visuals were fantastic also avatar
trailer
fun fact we uh did not see the avatar
trailer yeah we we skipped the avatar
trailer we
literally drive ourselves we literally
ha uh i had olivia texas when the
trailer was done and then we
ran up there back to it there were yeah
it's to react so we could react to it
because
when dr strange played a spider-man no
way home we had to cover our eyes like
we could hear it but we covered our eyes
and people were like no they saw it i'm
like then [ __ ] this i'm going to really
go the extra yeah i'm going to sit
outside turn outside
who recognize us who sat behind us and
they know they saw us run up there and
say something we recorded it on
instagram yeah short youtube shorts just
[ __ ]
beyond reasonable doubt we did not see
that
so much proof of this they didn't even
get to see robert pattinson because they
were outside hanging out there's a top
gun
clip that they they played a scene
before the movie and we missed it
because we were dodging the avatar
trailer
after three watches i'm left in a weird
place with ds2 i really like it have a
blast watching it but i also might be in
the bottom three of mc fun bottom three
i put a lot more movies in the bottom
three than this
i mean technically you know but three
there what a weirdo
five or six minutes crazy like
eight or nine
yeah
there's
more like before yeah
[Laughter]
yeah well i'm sorry you feel that way
that's interesting well if you really
like it and you have a blast watching it
but if it's the bottom three i'm like
very confused when you must like most of
it you must like most of the movies yeah
that is the thing is like most marvel
movies are exceptional so it i get your
conflict it's just an interesting
feeling like i'm happy i'm no longer
well like the lowest cinema second
lowest for this is b plus and i'm like
that's no c yeah there's a much bigger
leap honestly between b plus and a c and
what a giant run of 34 movies if your
lowest is a b yeah yeah um one darcy
one darts thanks for the sticker my
friend dick
patrick fowley
i find wanda's fall to the dark hold in
a way to explain how even a person
healing can still lose it shows that
overcoming grief is hard and even if you
do get through it doesn't mean you're
fixed that's i think a big part of the
message of the movie with both strange
and wanda is like
she doesn't get her children and equally
equally painful strange can't be with
his uh his woman and happiness is not a
destination
yeah i love all of that i wish i felt it
more from the movie it's impossible to
be happy don't even try to achieve
happiness so constantly search for it
yeah that's what life is just searching
for happiness never feeling so when
you're on your deathbed you go i should
have made more money yep capital why
didn't i work more hours
i think about material girl in the
material world zack pole
bro professor x and visionary both died
three times
bro these two guys
yeah bro
augusto luyo bro hello
hello from south africa bruh uh really
enjoyed the movie uh do you guys think
that earth 838 professor x recognized
the scarlet witch as the daughter of
maganito i wanted at least a moment
i would have loved it because that would
have given us [ __ ] acknowledge
mutants man
even with the giant like x-men accurate
statue behind her in that sequence like
they did it but they didn't no i don't
know why they didn't they could have
they should have brought demanding much
more than 20 minutes more where
everything would just get a three-hour
slow ass batman movie we could have
gotten it yeah fast face adventure yeah
we'll be here for doctor strange you
don't have to convince us
yeah we'll show up it made the 10th most
ever in his opening weekend
kim
and a half hour i've changed
far from home mysterio well i mean they
can show it less times a day maybe but
uh spider-man far from home mysterio
introduces himself and names peter's
world is 616. along with that the first
thing chavez and strange encounter in
838 is a memory store similar in
functionality as barf
similar functionally as barf oversight
coincidence connection i'm glad you
brought this up
because i think that mysterio and all
the things he said in far from home were
in fact true and i've maintained
since that that is the multiversal
beginning i still think that jonah is
the first multiversal character we met
because he's a he's a being that looks
the same in multiple universes but i
think far from home was our first taste
of multiverse they say multiverse a lot
in doctor strange one but i think that
mysterio is someone that knows the scope
of the multiverse and i do think that's
going to come into play later if and
when jakey jakes comes back maybe he
just scientifically figured out that
using your dream that dreams were
somehow connected the dots that dreams
were um because he invented the barf
technology which involves memories in
mind that he figured out that dreams
connect you to multiverse versions of
yourself that's a fun idea and then he
was like we're earth 616 because another
mysterio knows what earth we're from
we're honored over the [ __ ]
first you had me in the first half not
gonna lie
you know yeah i like that i like the
dream element callum picard what about
the gargantos fight amazing effects and
the death was one of the biggest
reactions of the whole film i think it
was really well oh yeah i love the
gouging of the eye and then the actual
additional like the
stem yeah
yeah and then ocular nerve yeah ocular
nerve one that is some beautiful cgi
especially because that is like a pretty
broad daylight there's a lot of
expression in his eyeball too i thought
they managed to capture felt like a
really and it felt like a doctor trained
comic like if you flip through and you
see that [ __ ] like that's exactly
uh roboto studios again my issue was
that it feels thank you roboto you've
contributed a lot during this stream
that that
deserves to be recognized my issue is
that it feels not urgent
the goal is there the stakes are there
but where's the urgency to keep chavez
safe how is it that dead man's chest did
goal stakes urgency better 16 years ago
you know it is one of the first movies i
compared it to i was uh pirates of the
caribbean deadman i was just like i'm
the whole journey i'm like this is a lot
of the same problems i had and i love
dead man's chest i don't know the
correlation but i enjoy that parallel
yeah i would is is there more that we're
missing no yeah there's there's more
oh you guys stop the meandering guys
no no i'm not reloading more i'm just
like
is there that the the
no you guys come before my mom she knows
this she's watching too if there's
anything my mom prioritizes in her
life's work so she knows
no you do this first
yes
sorry i'm late um oh golly all right
i agree with the lack of urgency and i
agree with the lack of stakes because
that's the emotion part i did enjoy the
spectacle i did enjoy the story i did
enjoy those things didn't feel the
stakes well that's why i also think the
illuminati not making that about scarlet
witch
about strange undercuts the momentum a
lot yeah because if they were like you
mean the scarlet like if they were
treating it like a serious threat about
the scarlet witch and then that's why
professor x rolls in and he explains
something about like because he has some
history with a wanderer or whatever like
that's why i it's not that's not just me
wanting a wish that's just me thinking
that would have storytelling emergency
popping and you literally could have had
them kept in the cage and like that
scene could happen because that's like a
different story now you're introducing
about stranges in this very moment with
the illuminati when i'm like now it's
pulling away from the main story which
is we gotta get the [ __ ] away from wanda
right we gotta keep her safe
i agreed
so yeah gal murderer also dead man's
chest yeah good move i love that match
it's great i love that movie kevin feige
used to have full creative control in
marketing but since the change in
management that was taken away and
there's a suit who has finals say in a
lot of that now rock of [ __ ] man can't
figure we know how to do it best yeah i
would have loved to have seen his
trailers for this i'm glad he's here
he has a hat that says editing
it's just gotta it's just gotta have a
logo on it it's the editor above all hat
but it's a water
oh yes kevin make it happen yeah it
seems like something's up with the
marketing my ver i think the film and
horror was outstanding but i think they
tried to rely on cameos to carry the
movie i truly enjoyed it but it failed
to set up more i don't think the movie
tried to rely on cameos i think the
advertising did yeah i think the movie
made a movie that had cameos that felt
the right amount of like this is a
moment if you think about the movie by
itself like without expectations they
even did cool like and then this
revealed this reveal they did a little
behind the shot with the shield then
they had xavier come out last the cameos
worked but the fan expectations because
of the marketing that messed it up in my
opinion i agree
from branagh to ytt favaro favaro yeah
fabra to shane
who's your favorite directorial
transition in the superhero saga oh i'm
tempted to say favro however like
favro's style is not really defined for
me
like i can't tell you what john
favreau's style is
universes i can't i just can't tell warm
world building science based it's like
lion king jungle book he's got the most
versatility but yet there's nothing
there's nothing really distinct about
his style or shane black's a genius of
style for me it's why tt because i think
thor what he's done in thor ragnarok
that feels like a taiko itd film and he
reinvented the character in a way that
got people excited for like they're
bringing them back for thor love my
thunder i don't are you you're not the
biggest
right
you're not a big ragnarok guy but this
one looks better to me i oh i'm a i love
ragnarok i think it's i don't think it's
as like hilarious as everyone finds it
to be i do find it i think like the it
he managed because it was tiger ytd he
was known for like the comedy or
sometimes dramady aspects
but something about the colorful flair
that he brought to ragnarok still felt
like taiko ytd to me he really felt like
a taika ytd film that has a
a love for the comic style but really
made it his own and and it managed and i
think that there's a reason why that one
resonated so much stronger than the
other two i'm into that uh mine even
though koi doesn't like it and hates all
good things i hate happiness uh mine's
john watts uh untethered from john watts
tethered i think no way home i feel like
it took him a while to get there though
uh mine is schumacher to christopher
nolan
uh hey kimbrell's back the best way to
pay off the cameos uh in uh in my
opinion would be a scene of 616 reid
richards waking up from a nightmare or
any universe damn this seems like a
common thought great mind
is it not
and but but by the rules that still
means and then you go an extra layer and
it's wanda creating the nightmares
what you're doing insurance
wakes up and he's like whoa
i just want to get some i am so
exhausted of all these multi-verses i'm
going mad what is this postcard
when is it gonna end
and then bruce campbell comes in and he
goes it's over it's overheard rolling
the actual credits over the boat
and then they start interacting with the
credits and using those as weapons
and then coulson wakes up and describes
that he's not dead agents of shield
this is gonna be a good move and then
patton oswalt describes all to us
true sea cloaks patch was the same color
of the illuminati strange as chloe
that's a great great detail the one reed
was holding when they killed oh wow
fascinating that was used for the patch
good call great call how did you catch
that damn it took me to the second
viewing to realize oh there's a big blue
patch and like so yeah the big blue
cloak he was holding it was it was
almost ceremonial where greed was
holding the cloak that is genius i'm
wondering if that'll tie into 616
multiversal cloak personality earth 666.
brandon
yeah brandon passmore thank you buddy do
you feel this could have done a better
job as a series
yeah
i love the theater experience i would
opt for like a clone wars thing where
you do get like
even and i think an animated version
that sam raimi directs would be cool
like just a few of them like eight
episodes or something just to like you
see it's a few just a full series it's a
full series of eight episodes you know
what i mean i'm not going to talk
homework like eight seasons
no but like uh like you see the whole
thing with that strange they were
describing yeah at the illuminati you
see wanda go on the mountain and then
kind of go through her journey yeah you
see america's moms just go at it you see
white vision watching america conceived
[Laughter]
if they don't know i'm watching does
that mean i'm watching um
if i've changed in this moment am i
still vision watching two ladies
this vision is a [ __ ] perfect that's
just sketchy dude
oh man
we should stop i love you guys so much
the only real see what i did there ha ha
that's what we've done reason we're
still hoping on youtube
to watch you guys oh thanks there's no
one else on the platform that's
enjoyable trust me oh you're the only
one i hate them all ryan warren is
mephisto controlling wanda for a greater
goal
is always there they should do that they
should have it be mephisto has been
showing king the conqueror the sacred
time thanos
[ __ ] devil man played by colin hanks
i don't want it i want colin firth from
the gentleman as mephisto
reflective studios imagine if wanna
bondo with america over loss or strange
even where was the room to breathe it
was missing it was missing that's where
it was it was on the cutting room floor
as they say yeah once the dark hole got
destroyed and it's like we're going to
wonder
what's going on no one will ever talk
again
we're just going to explain everything i
wonder
david lemin uh very i wish i wish we
that is a good call about wanda bought
like an actual conversation yeah one
totes
tote bags david lemin very enjoyed uh
the movie but everything everywhere all
at once is a better use of the
multiverse than that don't try to spoil
it
yeah say no more say no more
there are several universes from that
right i will be reacting to doctors i
will be reacting i'm excited to get your
thoughts i am
yeah i'm going to watch it on a on my
phone jimx mafia that's the way that's
the way spaghetti really honestly i
thought it was all that interesting
visually not exciting
no good fights scoop
spaghetti reed richards and living
tribunal in the multiverse of madness
everyone got so jasmine
was such a moment that was so cool yeah
but it means nothing if you don't no
it's just big it has just a good visual
it's so
someone out there is like legends of the
hidden temple the tribunal was like what
was that
people just fly through here
just a giant like cut away and just a
giant hand
and that was another thing they put in
the trailers that made us think it was
um i digress
uh as we were i just like this as a
title spaghetti read richard than the
living tribunal in the multiverse
watching and enjoying every talk and
reaction since five years much love and
glory for the soon to be one million
never stop posting even if you want to
just like ben affleck never stop i must
stop posting i can't stop posting
i'm just re-uploading the same content
oh thank you so much for being here and
for sticking with us reynaldo torres
torres
anyone else going nuts over x-men 97
theme song yep i did not know it played
in the first i was brought up earlier i
didn't know it played the first time and
then i saw it in the credits and i was
like where was it in the movie because
people were cheering you were watching
it might be my favorite needle drop in
marvel like if that includes guardians
of the galaxy hearing that in a theater
i did not realize how much it would
affect me it might be my favorite needle
drop but does that mean it's the
animated version i thought so i thought
it was the animated but they're bringing
the but that sucks if that's just how he
dies he's not in the next 197. yeah yeah
if that's just how he died it's an
orchestral so therefore it's a variant
all right
all right
let's just save my soul there it is
we're back x-men 97 i think uh all the
uh
how would you all i asked
as campy of this but i also wanted to
know which strange was your favorite
in the film
the one i expected to like the least i
really really loved zombie strange i had
so much fun seeing him like doing like
the weird tarot tropes and the talking
out of the like i loved all of that and
that is not usually my thing and the
cloak of bodies was so metal i i loved
the thing i thought i'd hate and i and i
disliked things i thought i'd love it it
was spectacular like the whole third act
strange yeah
oh also oh the sequence where he's
pulling in the candles and he hovers and
he gets like it literally was like comic
book art i love that sequence the third
act of this movie slaps for me so hard
you know i i think what's really
effective is that even in the trailers i
brought this point up in another video
but even in the trailers the fact that
they show you reanimated strange
the movie's
so effective in that moment and that
point and what it's doing
that
what he's when when christine's like
um you know like but don't you need a a
strange alive there to dreamwalk through
and then he says who said anything about
being alive so cool i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's right
and the whole candle thing to make it
feel so spooky i don't know man i was so
i was so vibrant so occult so seance you
know like the good comics of doctor
strange and that's a great yeah it's
like it builds you up not only for just
oh cool you know horror movie sci-fi
thing but it's also a wrestling hardcore
of the oath visuals i definitely have
reservations to go all right we got to
make sure we
jones i think the mcu is building to
x-men versus avengers yeah great cool
whatever long game
i think he's building x-men versus
avengers uh would they do that right up
front nuts not
phase four of x-men like it'd be deep i
think they got to treat the mutants like
they're a threat they also got to treat
the mutants like their uh their own
thing enough to let them grow enough to
care yeah i should let all the avengers
be really racist towards the music
because yes you were like
spiderman's like you guys are gross
[Laughter]
weirdos
vision's walking through a wall by kitty
drive like what's wrong with you oh
what's in your dna oh yeah jeez x jeans
oh [ __ ] aliens
hang out
[Laughter]
just got back from my third viewing of
the film in 333d because i'm a dork and
i think this might be my favorite doctor
strange story in the mcu
continued in another super chat a little
quicker
part two what i felt was missing about
the first film was steven's compassion
when i heard donna's name dropped it
became crystal clear how much sam raimi
understands what makes this character
tick
uh that's what you were speaking to how
much that moment meant to you in the
character and i and i really do think
that dr strange's arc is growing here
and i do think the characterizations are
improving here i just wanted the
emotional weight to feel like as good as
those moments like that is a moment that
i loved of doctor strange but it didn't
like leave with me personally yes
jay's fan domination wait wait a minute
oh wow you're the only one to bring up
donna there's the only one to bring up
donuts yeah
you know what i mean like this it's just
resonance it's good thanks for thanks
for mentioning that good detail actually
actually i really do appreciate you
mentioning that thanks buddy jay's fan
domination nation i love your channel
guys i've been watching for a long time
now and i just wanted to show support
thank you so much that means the world
cup whoa thank you wowie
it was like huh oh [ __ ] i forgot
i meant to put 99 cents
and he's asked like a hundred things
please guys please please i missed it
our strange recognize the fantastic four
didn't you chart in the 60s confirmed
they have been missing in our main
universe this whole time trapped in the
negative zone by bay wait that is true
yeah he said didn't you shot in the 60s
yeah the people are usually yelling and
screaming when he says it i mean
he's the thing i've been wanting
happening yeah yeah
i mean i'm pretty sure he's just saying
that they look like and sound like a
band but also extrapolate i'm gonna
extrapolate no i think it's a hint
it'd be probably i would love that i
would love their if their does he say
reed richards from the fantastic four
does he say that no but he's credited as
it but i know but does this uh does does
he say fantastic i didn't even hear that
i don't think so okay i don't think he's
gonna hear that
fantastic
all right
i think i no i thought it was i i
thought i thought it was a hint towards
that
to explain where they haven't been
well cool iden higgins to clarify on my
previous comment the illuminati were
very overconfident
and underestimated wanda and i think
that payoff was very well done and
satisfying oh good i'm glad hell yeah i
definitely feel echoes of that for sure
uh gripes aside alan ling
rip
um
they underestimated her
i'm not therefore so i'm losing brand
cells
hey guys i just jumped into the stream
thanks for joining us late uh i don't
know two hours ago i don't know what you
guys covered but greg that was uh what
was the 75 of the movie that worked out
for you and the 25 that didn't work what
do you guys think now i think it's much
better now and i found thing i find that
there are things in that 25 that don't
bother me as much like i don't think the
pacing is as off as it like there are
some pacing issues i think arts had off
but nowhere near
the amount i thought it was before where
it felt like such a like it was
always in a hurry the second time around
it didn't feel nowhere near as fast
paced to me i was a as i'm not i'm not
having to like really process everything
they're saying so i could actually sit
back and enjoy it like i know people who
heard a lot of what's in it so when they
watched it they actually were like no it
was actually really didn't feel as fast
and i i know a lot of people who felt
that way the second time around the 75
percent of the movie that really worked
for me is like all the visual stuff the
action sequences wanda specifically the
25 that didn't work
i mean i i think when they get to the
838 planet and just some of the [ __ ]
there like i just found myself craving
more i think mordo was boring
i think um the
i do think the illuminati is underused
and underutilized they like they they
kind of feel like it's so there's the
stuff about it that i [ __ ] love but
then there's stuff about i'm not a big
fan there's some really rough talk
editing in the 838 planet like the scene
with mortar when they're fighting they
cut to him doing on a close-up and then
he's suddenly out and running and then
they they never see xavier leave he's
just gone there's there's some weird
pace like [ __ ] wanda other wanda when
when when scarlet witch leaves her she's
just like my boys yeah and they just
[ __ ] lose disasters
mordo and then they just cut tomorrow
and xavier's just left how did mordo get
picked yeah
just like was just down there and so
many weird yeah there's some weird
editing choices for sure like even when
strange is like walking on the in the
streets of 838 and then for like a
second it's like america and then just
try to make it all like panicky with
like the crazy framer i'm like
what what's going on it's not obviously
crossing the street you guys are just
you guys are traveling in a multiverse
she's crossing issues not really
anything to do with uh visuals or
visuals stay top notch me like
you want more extension photography i
think this is one of the best looking
marvel movies i've ever seen so yeah
it's really just i think we've covered a
lot of it throughout john willis
joe willis our one-liners were a bit
cringe dialogue was exposition heavy the
big moments of the film never had a
moment to breathe with a wink nudge
after each one i enjoyed it but cameos
were disappointing yeah i mean it's like
the the use of cam just used to cameo is
not great
and there were one liners that really
bothered me with one-liners yeah i
didn't really i mean the opening like
there was some spider-man one-liners and
stuff but like it didn't bother me there
were some one-liners that felt a little
wrote just just like the whole thing
with uh dr strange and wong like you
know so no pressure you know like oh
that went great like i thought that was
charming in the moment but i was also
like i feel like we could have a more
unique joke than just this classic joke
that apparently just exists everywhere
yeah i see you're saying yeah all
multiverses yeah and those things just
speak to like i feel like maybe another
pass on some of this stuff might have
helped you know it's like i fully
believe michael waldron and company are
capable late night alum which uh movie
or show will america chavez reappear
i could see her coming as soon as i
i can see her reappearing as soon as
miss marvel i kind of doubt it but i
could see her appearing as soon as there
with her power set i would expect a
young avengers ask thing to be her next
appearance they should just have her
appear once in every movie just i mean
you should have heard hey
she's running through the background
yeah
oh my that would actually be fun really
funny i just wanna uh you know like a an
lgbtq drama
i mean i think we're getting one without
her figuring out her place in the world
when she finally
reconnects with her moms
you know people love that in certain
states cinematic goodness i really loved
how dark this movie was how much they
got out of their way uh to make wanda
gradually become an actual monster was
beautifully executed the tunnel chase
with her was truly demented yes it was
yeah i love that yes eerie and nasty as
heck thank you cinema goodness
zoe's movie corner
so still no mutants are we asking for
too much or is this as close as we'll
get to mutants into the mcu now we're
getting mutants they're coming they're
just going to come as a full force i i
don't think they're going to come as a
cameo i don't think they're going to
come
and a half measure i think we're getting
full on movies and tv shows kevin feige
said he's doing a creative retreat for
the next 10 years that is x-men based
x-men are coming huh
a creative what uh there's a creative
retreat they're kevin feige's on right
now and he said he's planning the next
10 years of marvel wowie x-men that's
what's coming like there's going to be
10 like x-men are going to make avengers
look it's a cinema card creative retreat
what does that look like gilbert zoo
rwanda
almost goes [ __ ] rage-filled kevin
feike
we need ten years of content you all
need to do better especially you trailer
people just taking off hats but it's my
angry hat
kevin feige and the multiverse of hats
calmer zoo wanda almost goes brutal at
times in one division it's only a vision
this is my sex hat
every meeting he rolls up he just has a
briefcase he unclips opens it up puts on
the first hat and here we are we are off
to the races i need to talk to you what
are we talking about let me get ahead i
didn't just yeah i didn't know what
happened
this is my item one hat you'll have to
wait for your addendum until i put on
the addendum hat uh wanda almost goes
brutal at times in one division it's
only vision being there and confronting
her and pulling her back being her
better angel that kept her down the more
compassionate past a solid point maybe
that's why i wasn't in the movie to keep
her from their batteries that's a really
solid point well that's one thing about
this movie that does i guess you can't
really credit the movie necessarily for
it but little things like that that at
first you gripe about also have this
shadow side where i'm like but that's
actually kind of interesting to
entertain like what is wanda like with
no vision you know at all also i mean to
go back to our joke for me gonna go the
moment of excitement we're gonna get
when kevin does dawn on an x-men hat
because that's gonna be a moment like i
do think i do think we need to be
patient with the cameos and see them for
what they are versus what the x-men are
and i'd rather let the x-men come across
naturally than force them in yeah i
think they'll just be like shut up
they're coming yeah
see we can do them if we want just wait
the next that's going to be the next uh
presenter like shareholder day just shut
up it's coming stop asking questions and
don't look for leaks eddie eddie eddie
do you think reed's child will get
revenge he will bite off wanda's head
i don't think we'll ever see 838 in 838
my dad was a loser
grant for girl
oh that's good yeah i don't think we're
going to see 838 again but i think the
allusion to that was the moment grant
fergara why haven't christine died in
the mcu 616. if it's supposed to be an
absolute point in all universes
definitely could have ended her in
multiverse they should have died at the
wedding garganto should have murked her
right there not in all universes just in
uh that one universe yeah i also i i
don't think killing i i think fridging
women is not the move like i think
killing off like love interest is is a
very like it's a we've done that yeah
for decades it's not it's not the move
bobby cat's a quaddle uh 616 thing is
terrible but casuals will like it
what i think he's trying to be
the naming of
it being 626.
whenever someone uses like casuals or
mid i'm always just assuming they're
trying to be made you yeah like i just
don't know what their smooth brain and
what their goals are rhett proctor i was
very disappointed by that illuminati
scene i am certainly hoping john
krasinski comes back as reed richards he
was great
same hope yeah samesies also shouts out
to alison rivers in the main chat saying
i've always seen bill hater is reed
richards interesting choice lords of the
abyss null so that prophecy fought down
for me for one second again okay lord of
the abyss no
so that prophecy guarantees wanda
survival ruled the cosmos and threatened
the multiverse and her durability was
insane not a glass cannon
so that prophecy guarantees wanda's
survival which prophecy the the rule the
cosmos and threatened them yeah i think
that's what they're saying and her
durability was insane yeah yeah yeah i
think they're just saying like she's
hearty and ready for all of it yeah and
i mean that would track she's a nexus
being she's yeah she's all powerful and
she's like freaking strong
yeah the strong
that was a question we we kept asking
was it was is is her nexus status in
this universe is that there's only one
the scarlet witch and the rest are
wandas with powers because there's a
dark hole in every no because we saw
another scarlet witch entity as the
statue
we saw her dressed fans scarlet witch
there so yeah now there are other
witches
but can there only be one at a time is
what i'm saying and like one across the
multiverse like like the previous
scarlet witch let's say that whoever
that was yeah was every other iteration
of them just them with base powers and
then there's one scarlet witch it's like
all the way roided up i assume there has
to be a singular entity nexus being like
kang
okay i assume at that level of power so
all the other wandas are at like a lower
level yeah i think they're still in
scarlet witch powers but the scarlet
witch cool nice joey b last last of the
main super chats welcome welcome as soon
as the film started it definitely felt
like it was picking up from spider-man
toby finally someone echoed my sentiment
from the wedding to the building fight
when on may was uh got taken much love
to sam raimi but this wasn't it for me
i'm sorry to hear that i didn't really
went on a journey i was like you oh
i was like we're having such a great
share i mean oh oh i guess not
not for everybody not for everybody is
that everybody
yeah i think we might we might oh my god
we're caught up to the end we see what
this is what those uh stream labs do but
guys thank you all for for joining
and uh and hey the prophecy held true 82
percent of people are interested in
seeing coy's
this is an updated poll with only two
options so the theory
uh the theory tracked let's see craig's
like i don't know about this channel i
really want to do that
do this [ __ ] this is actually an
idea i want to stream back up in and
then we got uh
2096 right now 2096. over over
1700 20 000. 96. all right all right
here i'll figure out the math for you
exactly
[Laughter]
82 percent of that many okay how many
votes did you say 2096.
oh my we do have some more of these i
know we do all right uh hey abercon
after the battle with scarlet witch mr
fantastic will return as dr string and
now that dr strange has the third eye
uh and tainted by evil he will return uh
as dr evil for the mcu crossover with
austin power
everything's a crossover yes it is bring
it everything is cool when you share
this mike myers universe he's got a
movie coming out where he's playing like
10 people nice yeah dude that's all i
care about him doing
i mean yeah the people want it pizza boy
153 son of pizza pop uh bruce campbell
as mephisto
and also do you think it's possible the
scarlet witch is a nexus being uh
well wanda is not what i was talking to
is like kang obviously there's multiple
kangs but one is kang the conqueror in a
sense where like kang replaces himself
with worse and worse versions of himself
but there are multiple kangs i just feel
like and this is not founded in any
other thing we've been told i can't
imagine there being multiple wandas to
that power set so i do feel like other
scarlet witches exist but not to the
level of the scarlet witch but also like
i imagine different universes have
different strengths and different power
sets like some thanos's might be
stronger than others um so i don't know
how they're going to actually quantify
nexus beings in this universe because it
is different in the comic books then i
think they're setting it up here but i'm
not sure
yeah so i got a lot of crap for saying
that like that there could be another
wanda who already did the
the no more mutants already right what i
thought they were going with they're
like charlotte which is the nexus being
i'm like they don't even like that
that's what i'm saying is like i never
find what this [ __ ] means because the
next thing would theoretically be a
singular entity a dot in space-time and
it seems like this nexus being of
scarlet witch is so connected to the
darkhold right yeah so i don't know what
they're considering and i just i
consider kang our nexus being for now
but i don't know what that's going to be
reflected on yeah true destin hellfire
so i'm not the only one that found it
odd that wanda threatened by reed uh
that wanda threatened by reed saying his
children will still have someone to
raise them going off one division i feel
like she wouldn't uh or wasn't going to
strip children of their parents
especially uh how dear family is
different she's willing to kill her own
self for her children like she's she's
not focused on other people she's she's
so selfish she doesn't give she's she's
getting progressively more selfish yeah
and that's darkhold you know confused
but but yeah like at that point in the
story she like doesn't she's not
maternal towards other people's kids if
they want to start it off that way it
might be a little bit different yeah in
that moment i mean of course that's not
gonna work because he's like hey i have
a family that's intact i can relate to
you
you know the whole point is no dude you
can't uh expecto go do you think
spider-man will get his black suit like
in the og secret wars instead of using
the symbiote i think what they might do
is be clever and have that ooze kind of
chill out for a little bit and then when
they're in the secret war that ooze
comes to play and that way it ties into
secret war in its own way but it's also
using the continuity they've already
established because the the actual story
is a little silly in the little 80s
where spider-man's like my clothes are
tattered let me go in this thing and
then he's like this is crazy and then
it's like that thing happens to be an
alien and it's like what a crazy thing
that happened to me like i think what
they've set up kind of works a bit more
than spider-man being like i don't
notice these changes in my puberty self
i'm just excited to hear tom holland's
cookie monster uh venom voice yes eddie
gucci gates
oh crap uh what's different from loki
multiverse and doctor strange multiverse
that was not mentioned
or kang
i i don't i mean i think they're trying
to play it like they're not different
like they are the same multiverse uh
one's time one space seemingly like you
know i think what people get confused by
is tva versus incursion that's what
that's and that's why i'm saying like
what we've had in the six one sense is a
tva thing yeah what we've had in this
movie is incursion i don't think our 616
universe had an incursion which is why i
thought the clia thing was poorly
written to elude the problem is it
alludes to something to set up a
cliffhanger but it also alludes to
something that would confuse people with
tva but if incursion happens what's
incursion the the planet planet's
colliding planet's colliding but the
multiverse is depending okay but if the
multiverse is
wouldn't that still be considered a
what's what's the word in tva that they
use again
a nexus level event yeah wouldn't that
still be a nexus event it would and
that's what's confusing about the clia
thing is it's like how have these things
happen simultaneously all right just
keep that open for now
like later on uh scenes with dean
i thought of a fun theory since thank
you for the super chat since it was said
that this reed richards has children
what if since he was killed the
descendant of this king was the one that
became evil it would make sense to have
why this king would want to conquer the
multiverse is there more
no okay um
i mean not not immediately okay
yes because uh we haven't met we don't
know which kang
a38 is we don't know what six one's we
we don't know our kang's yet and i do
think we're going to get a lot more of
the designations of multiverses with
kang i do think that might be the globe
hopping multiverse hopping movie we want
later i do think that stuff's to come
and fantastic four just moved up
so i do think we're going to see some
multiversal stuff in fantastic four
quantum mania heck yeah black agar bolt
gone
none of guys to mitigate you
in retrospect or whatever he says it
wouldn't have made a lot of sense for
this film to have uh have had the wild
cameos people wanted or expected tom
cruise etc the concept of the multiverse
was just introduced i think the
inevitable secret wars movie will be
what some wanted i think we're gonna get
a tease of that in fantastic four and
then i think it's gonna go full tilt
later but i think i think we've just
begun the multiverse oh absolutely i
would i would hope so how can you i i do
question if after you go through secret
wars
how can the mcu ever be as exciting
after that
i don't know what's bigger than secret
wars
yeah i don't know how you can go bigger
go smaller but more
impactful yeah i don't know i i mean if
they're bad cameos cameos a movie that's
what they're getting from a movie
a malcolm universe yeah we're going into
this we gotta start working with dc
they'll get desperate crossovers after
secret wars we have to build darks what
was it dark claw yeah wolverine and
batman oh bro
see it's working bring it dark claw's
coming confirm that would be awesome
anew
touri alturi can't quite read that uh
the lack of inner conflict except
towards the end for wanda's character
made it too one-dimensional even in 3d
shakey loved raymie's direction the
camera angles sweeping shots and all of
it we'll give it a three point two five
out of five
three it's a really high rating three
and quarter steps almost exactly my
rating actually like i gave it uh it
sounds better than a b plus that's
almost exactly a b yeah if you multiply
that by 20 like a b though so five times
twenty is a hundred so three point two
five thousand twenty is you say sixty
plus yeah when you have options of a
plus
to a to a minus to a wait you know what
i'm going to do
that's a 65 that's actually like a like
rates everything in percentages
correlate to a letter grade 65 is a d is
it 60 yeah the 60's so that's it that's
like a d because the 70's is a c 80's is
a b so if that was three and a half
times 20 that'd be seven i mean that'd
be three and a half times two yeah
that'd be 70 would be a c if that was
another quarter up it'd be a c that's a
d so i gave it higher but three point
two five stars is like a three three out
of five two two and a half out of five i
was like good so like so i do the yeah
so it is kind of like a b yeah three
point two five i'm saying but why does a
b sound so much lower because it's it's
not an a it's it's second tier and
that's not bad see but that doesn't
sound like second tier three point two
five out of five something well yeah
cause in american grading it's
technically the fifth tier right right
two yeah because a plus is so impossible
which is why a bell curve is how we
should rate things because like i think
i consider right one movie [ __ ] it up
for everybody
i lost here while you guys explained
elementary
808 happy mother's day to wind uh and
just wanted to such a big contribution
thank you yeah and just wanted to show
some love to the channel being a viewer
has been one of the few things i have
stayed committed to in life this is lana
uh which speaks to how great the channel
is hugs and kisses lana oh thanks lana
is a beautiful woman yeah and committed
to the channel and but if she turns evil
even hotter well we learned that about
greg today
let's get some variants in here
thank you
some evil [ __ ] olivia but not he knows
the assignment the illuminati in the
cliche horror characters that was told
to run
but run towards danger then got killed
off one by one see my issue with that is
that
mordo knew what the scarlet witch was
and he doesn't try to warn them at all
right yeah that's
that's the biggest part because you
can't all seem unconcerned
they're all like yeah we got a scarlet
window that's another reason for the
nexus level being though is like maybe
their scarlet witch is like you know
because i don't i guess i guess that
would again make sense because yeah part
of me was like well i get it you know
like she's not your main priority
strangers but it seems like you would
need to deal with it at least
maybe she's like a seven on the power
scale we gotta shout out some people all
righty guys shout out some super chats
thank you cloud clouded
thank you for the sticker james
whitehead james would say it together
oh sorry anyone's talking at all james
whitehead
cameron
and catherine and joe thank you so much
gerald larry some pies
yes guys
we've never done a live stream under
four hours i am officially sick of
talking about doctor strength yeah we've
made it through we got more videos
coming this week though they're already
pre-recorded
we uh we shot the new rockstars uh
breakdown uh reaction to breakdown and
that is uh it's like about an hour 20
minutes of footage that we have on our
end so we are going to edit that tonight
spend the rest of mother's day yeah
sorry mom i gotta go to lunch first uh
so i'm gonna we'll do you actually late
evening um why not
and uh but thank you guys so much thank
you stephanie for being here with your
son
uh i got to be hot for like two hours
nikoi is hot you're so hot koi you're
the only one with a mom today so we've
only one mom you can you're the only one
mama's koi i didn't have my mom's
not canceled in certain places guys
thank you so we don't do these live
streams that often we were thinking of
trying to figure out a way to do a
weekly one and obviously one of the koi
ones i mentioned with you guys as one is
uh as an idea but yeah as we're slow
we've been looking at options to upgrade
the quality of the stream so we know we
don't have the best quality looking
streams and it's something we want to
improve and that's and i brought that up
earlier on in the chat and uh also
uh we do have a podcast so we wanna
start doing more of these and we just
like the interactive nature of it to
make it really stand out so thank you
all so much for being here thank you koi
for being here
um buddy john thanks for holding down
the fort is moderating everything again
happy mother's day to everyone who's
gonna be with their mothers and happy
mother's day to all the mothers and
happy mother's day to
especially stephanie and
you guys are awesome uh thank you so
much for being here and participating
with us we are almost at a million
subscribers i don't really talk about it
that often just want to kind of get
through organically by people who just
choose to subscribe
so without us like hey eight thousand
more
eight thousand more send it to your
friends tell your moms that's the seven
thousand more but whatever oh yeah you
heard it here new rock stars sucks
from them themselves from them
themselves so yeah thank you guys uh so
much for it's been an amazing journey
and you know to know that you know we
have a channel that gets so involved
with one of the biggest franchises in
all of history and and to be a part of
that collective in some small fraction
is is so amazing and it's a lot of so
many opportunities so we don't take
these you know these
interactions or the viewership for
granted because yeah ever since one
division the channel's been much
much more successful in every single way
and so yeah i do not take that for
granted uh whatsoever uh neither of
these guys and so thank you guys we
appreciate you all yeah see you soon
reject nation and thanks to the super
sexy rejects for showing all your
support we'll see you guys soon end the
stream john yes sir keep that dashboard
open somehow if you know how to do that
we are saying bye
bye everybody bye-bye
second oh we ended on one thou over a
thousand views yeah it's good for us
that's good for us
and leave a like before you say bye
leave a like
much love everyone take care guys thank
you
it's over
it's over we're done
i cannot wait to trash talk everyone
individually
i hate